[Musique]
bonsoir nous voici donc réunis pour ce
débat entre les deux participants au deè
tour de l'élection présidentielle
monsieur Valérie Giscard et Monsieur
François mitteran ce débat a été
organisé par la commission de contrôle
avec l'accord des représentants des deux
candidats il sera dirigé par deux
journalistes choisis d'un commun accord
Michel cotta journaliste à RTL et
moi-même jean- boissonard journaliste à
l'expansion et chroniqueur à europin
nous devons veiller à l'organisation à
l'animation et au déroulement de ce
débat chaque candidat disposera de 50
minutes pour répondre aux questions que
nous leur poserons et qu'ils se poseront
l'un à l'autre puis il leur restera à
chacun 5 minutes pour conclure nous
avons regroupé en trois grands thèmes
les questions qui peuvent être posées le
premier autour des problèmes de
politique intérieure le deuxème sur les
questions de vie quotidienne des
Français et de la vie économique le 3e
sur les problèmes de politique
extérieure chacun de ces thèmes
sera se déroulera pendant 30 minutes
puis pendant une dizaine de minutes nous
poserons des questions de caractère plus
général avant que chaque candidat
conclue en 5 minutes la commission de
contrôle a demandé à ce que les
personnes qui sont présentes dans cette
salle ne manifestent pas leur sentiment
pendant le déroulement du débat aussi
nous les remercions d'aviance de bien
vouloir taire ou leurs enthousiasmes ou
leur réprobation
pendant la durée de la discussion
commençons donc par la politique
intérieure Michel cota pose la première
question j'ajoute que le tirage au sort
a désigné Monsieur François mitteran
pour parler le dernier pour conclure
cette émission et ce sera donc monsieur
Valéri giscardestin si vous voulez bien
qui parlera le premier alors Monsieur
Valéri giscardesttin monsieur miton au
fond à l'issue du deuxème tour vous avez
devant vous à peu près le même problème
vous avez obtenu l'un et l'autre le 26
avril plus de 25 % le cas du corp
électoral mais l'un et l'autre vous avez
besoin pour être élu d'un autre carart
vous François milteran vous avez besoin
des communistes et vous valerégis
cardestin vous avez besoin des électeurs
de Jacques Chirac alors ma première
question est celle-ci votre stratégie de
reconquête à l'égard des électeurs
Chirens n'est-elle pas trop rapide
lorsque vous dites Jacques Chirac a eu
raison parlez-vous seulement de sa lutte
contre la bureaucratie y a-t-il pour
vous un Jacques Chirac qui a eu raison
et un Jacques Chirac qui continuerait
d'avoir tort mademoiselle le tirage au
sort fait que je réponds le premier
bonsoir François mitteran je veux dire
dans quel esprit je suis venu participer
à ce
débat je crois je souhaite d'abord que
ce débat soit
utile les Françaises et les Français ont
un choix important à faire c'est un
choix important en raison de la
situation internationale en raison aussi
de des alliances politiques de l'un ou
de l'autre qui font que la société
française en tout cas la politique de la
France s'engagera dans des directions
différentes voir même opposé suivant que
vous-même monsieur mitéran ou moi seront
élus dimanche prochain j'ai lu ou
entendu que ce soir on dirait s'il y a
un vainqueur ou un vaincu je ne suis pas
venu pour cela c'est dimanche prochain
que les Français éclairés diront qui
doit être président de la République
j'ai pendant 7 ans eu des dialogues de
ce type avec un certain nombre de
dirigeants du monde je sais ce qu'on
sont les règles il n'y a pas d'agression
personnelle c'est tout à fait inutile
euh on ne consacre pas de long
développement au passé il est derrière
nous on regarde ce que l'on doit faire
et ce que l'on propose et c'est ce que
je compte faire avec vous ce soir alors
la question de de Michel Cotar je dirais
d'abord je crois pas que l'intérêt de ce
débat ce soit la politique du second
franchement je ne suis pas venu pour
cela je ce qui m'intéresse c'est l'enjeu
pour la France ce que Monsieur miter en
ferait ce que je ferais moi-même av
question en fait depuis 7 ans
j'ai pu gouverner enfin gouverner agir
comme président de la République avec un
gouvernement sans crise et sans
dissolution avec une majorité qui était
composée de deux tendances principales
le RPR et l'UDF elles se sont à certain
moment bien entendu au moment des
élections de 78 elles ont eu d'autres
moments des affrontements au total il a
jamais de motion de censure voté et il
n' jamais eu de crise politique je
n'aperçois aucune raison pour que cette
situation soit modifiée après l'élection
présidentielle j'observe d'ailleurs que
la totalité des dirigeants du RPR quasi
totalité des élus de cette formation
veulent bien soutenir à l'heure actuelle
ma candidature à la présidence de la
République et comme j'ai indiqué
moi-même qu'il n'y aurait pas de
dissolution il n'y a donc pas de
problème politique à cet égard il y aura
tout de suite la reprise de l'action
gouvernementale et parlementaire quand
j'ai dit que jacquesac avait eu raison
de mettre l'accent sur un certain nombre
de problèmes qu'est-ce que j'ai voulu
dire dès le début de cette campagne j'ai
dit que j'écouterai ce qui sera dit dans
cette campagne il y a des choses à
apprendre et une campagne révèle
toujours un certain état d'esprit de la
population les préoccupations de liberté
économique de déburaucratisation de la
société française d'allègement de
certaines charges ont été exprimé
notamment par Jacques Sirac et j'ai
indiqué que ce serait un des
enseignements à mettre en œuvre à
l'issue de cette élection mais il y aura
bien entendu beaucoup d'autres choses à
faire je pose une question à François
mitteran qui est dans la ligne de
celle-ci si vous êtes élu président de
la République vous avez dit que vous
formeriez un gouvernement ce
gouvernement se présentera-t-il devant
l'Assemblée
nationale j'aurais voulu poser une
question à Monsieur François mitteran
sur la question de Monsieur giscardestin
parce que Monsieur François mitteran a
déjà eu l'occasion de dire que il ne
serait pas le seul contraint de
dissoudre l'Assemblée si vous étiez élu
il ne m'intéresserait de savoir en votre
présence comment il argumente sur ce
point après avoir entendu ce qui d'être
dit par
monsieurcardtin j'avais moi aussi envie
de lui poser une question selon les
règles qui ont été établies ce sera donc
une question indirecte qui sera quand
même
entendue je voulais simplement qu'on
m'explique c'estàdire que l'autre
candidat bien
m'expliquer son raisonnement n'estil pas
ne tombeil pas dans le
vide le 17 mai
1974 vous déciez
c'était une autre élection
présidentielle il y a 7 ans je vous
demande de me croire vous vous adressez
aux Français vous ne serez pas déçu vous
serez surpris par l'ampleur par l'audace
par la rapidité du changement que je
veux introduire dans la politique de
notre pays et voilà que celui que vous
proclamez comme votre partenaire avec
lequel vous n'avez jamais eu d'ennui
peut-être quelques trouble dans la
majorité en tout cas jamais de motion de
censure
voilà que Monsieur Chirac responsable du
RPR vous répond le 22 mars 1981 au Club
de la Presse
d'OP la France est dans une situation
extraordinairement difficile je suis
certain que la voix que nous suivrons
monsieur giscardestin était réélu serait
la même et conduirait encore plus vite à
des désordres plus
graves deè citation il en aura pas
beaucoup toujours monsieur JAAC 9 mars
1981 à l'émission car surtable d'Antenne
2 nous sommes dans une situation
extrêmement préoccupante qui exige un
changement complet de politique et on ne
change pas de politique avec les mêmes
hommes une trè situation très rapide
toujours du même monsieur Chirac en date
du 4 mars 1981
oui je porte un jugement négatif sur le
septena sans doute monsieurardestin
considérez-vous que Monsieur
Chirac fait partie du cœur des
pleureuses mais il n'empêche que
j'aperçoise une contradiction entre
votre apparente tranquillité d'il y a un
moment sur l'avenir de votre majorité
pour peu que vous soyez élu et des
déclarations aussi contradictoires qui
montrent que si vous êtes élu vous
n'avez pas de
majorité vous mais bien entendu j'ai
auss une réponse à
apporter je constitueraiis un
gouvernement comme je le
dois après mon élection quand le moment
sera venu d'assumer mes
responsabilités ce gouvernement sera
composé des personnes femmes et hommes
que j'aurai choisi ou dont je discuterai
avec le Premier ministre que j'auraai
choisi ces personnes seront celles qui
auront approuvé mes options pendant la
campagne
présidencienne je ne seraiis pas en état
de débattre ou de discuter pour la
raison que la campagne présidentielle
m'absorbe qu'elle requiert entièrement
mon attention que c'est à elle que je
dois me consacrer qu'elle est d'une
nature particulière que ce n'est pas
l'affaire des partis et je constituerai
ce gouvernement après la désignation du
Premier ministre de telle sorte que
celles et ceux qui m'auront approuvé
dans ma démarche à moi candidat des
socialistes puisse s'y retrouver je
serai ainsi assuré de la cohérence de ce
gouvernement vous savez que d'autres
formations politiques nombreuses m'ont
rejoint pour le deè tour de
scrutin et bien entendu la question qui
m'est posé est-ce que vous ferez appel
au représentants de ces partis et
particulièrement du Parti communiste
pour rentrer dans ce gouvernement et je
rappellerai à cet égard que si l'union
de la gauche s'est rompu en
1977 c'est précisément autour de la
discussion sur un programme de
gouvernement je ne peux donc pas
considérer à l'heure actuelle que cette
question soit réglée et c'est une
question sérieuse la plus sérieuse de
toutes j'entends donc former un
gouvernement qui sera constitué avec par
ceux qui m'auront approuvé et ce n'est
qu'après l'élection présidentielle et en
vue des élections législatives dont nous
allons parler j'imagine tout à l'heure
que les organisations politiques
responsable examineront en commun si le
désir si elles sont en mesure ou non de
signer entre ell un contrat de
gouvernement et donc d'aborder les
élections législatives futures en
situation
d'accord quand au gouvernement que
j'aurai constitué qui sera tout
simplement le gouvernement de la
République il se trouvera devant le
problème suivant est-ce que il y aura 10
solutions décidé par le Président de la
République immédiatement et dans ce
cas-là il n'aura pas à se présenter
devant l'Assemblée nationale ou bien
est-ce qu'il y AA devant l'Assemblée
nationale en attendant la sanction de
cette assemblée pour peu qu'il y ait
sanction d'ailleurs ce qui veut dire que
je ne compte pas soumettre la politique
de ce
gouvernement à l'approbation de
l'Assemblée nationale élue en
1978 si je changeais d'avis c'est-à-dire
si j'avais le sentiment que cette
assemblée serait en mesure par exemple
de voter une réforme du mode de scrutin
ce qui serait très intéressant pour la
France vous êtes favorable isté
favorable dans quel sens je souhaite le
scrutin proportionnel tout de suite le
plutôt sera le mieux vous aussi monsieur
non pas du
touton si j'étais en mesure de le faire
je le ferais cela veut dire que je ne
pose pas le problème de la dissolution
en principe c'est simplement une
nécessité car je veux conduire ma
politique alors il y aura des élection
et le peuple
décidera alors d'abord premier remarque
vous fait des citations du premier tour
dans le premier tour chacun s'exprime
avec une certaine véhémence
bon trouver les citations à cet égard je
pourrais trouver également les citations
monsieur mitérant je n'en cherche pas
n'est-ce pas à votre propos ou de
vous-même sur monsieur Chirac j'en ai
une sous les yeux je ne la dirai même
pas tellement qu'elle est sévère donc
laissons cela m'intéresse pas en fait
monsieur Chirac a indiqué dès le
lendemain du premier tour oui monsieur
mitant VZ dire un mot est-ce que vous
l'autorisez monsieur je veux dire que
personnellement je ne compte pas faire
un gouvernement avec monsieur Chirac l'
de V élection donc le problème ne se
pose pas pour moi non mais je veux dire
quand on
invoque le témoignage de quelqu'un
encore faut-il porter sur ce quelqu'un
un jugement positif alors j'indique
simplement que le lendemain du premier
tour monsieur Chirac a indiqué qu'il
voterait pour moi à l'élection
présidentielle pour moi le critère comme
d'ailleurs vous l'indiquez pour vous
tout à l'heure ce sont ceux qui élisent
le président de la République et je note
je l'ai fait observé tout à l'heure que
la totalité des dirigeants de la
majorité des parlementaires de la
majorité avait indiqué qu'il voterait
désormais pour le président de la
République donc la question de ma
majorité quand je dis ma ce n'est pas un
ma possessif est réglé il n'y aura pas
d' dissolution un gouvernement sera
constitué ce gouvernement bien entendu
comportera des personnalités
représentatives de l'ensemble de la
majorité et il se mettra au travail pour
régler par priorité et pour adopter les
premiers textes concernant l'emploi et
notamment l'emploi des jeunes que je
voudrais voir figurer à la session
parlementaire de printemps mais la
réponse à ma question la réponse que
vous avez faite me surprend énormément
monsieur miteran nous ne sommes pas dans
un régime présidentiel ou personnel vous
m'avez fait des reproche à cet égard
dans le passé vous en avez fait encore
plus au général de Gaulle j'ai là un
certain nombre de textes mais la
Constitution dit que le gouvernement est
responsable devant le Parlement si vous
agissez ainsi que vous dites c'estàdire
si votre gouvernement ne va pas devant
le Parlement il ne pourra rien faire il
n'aura le droit de ne rien faire il
devra attendre le résultat des élections
nous n'avons pas en France un système
TER
qu'un président de la République vous ou
moi ou d'ailleurs le général de GA dans
le passé puisse nommer un gouvernement
qui ne rend de compte à personne et qui
prend des décisions importantes ceci est
impossible si donc il ne va pas devant
le Parlement il pourra faire qu'une
chose qu'est-ce qu'on appelle vous
connaissez la formule expédier les
affaires courantes or j'ai lu dans vos
déclarations je crois que c'est à
L'Express il me semble que vous aviez
l'intention de prendre tout de suite un
certain nombre de mesures vous dites par
exemple réduction du taux de la TVA sur
les produits de grande consommation
recrutement d'un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires ce sont des décisions
qu'un gouvernement chargé des affaires
courantes ne peut pas prendre donc la
procédure que vous indiquez n'est pas
réalisable le gouvernement doit aller
devant l'Assemblée l'assemblée peut ou
non le censurer vous pourriez comme
président de la République la dissoudre
ensuite à tout moment mais j'estime
qu'un gouvernement pour pouvoir exister
en France il n'y a jamais eu d'exemple
de sens contraire doit aller devant le
Parlement nous sommes dans un régime où
existe le contrôle parlementaire et
j'ajoute ensuite qui il y aura
d'importantes négociations
internationales au mois de juin
notamment sur l'Europe imaginez-vous un
gouvernement français qui aille dans les
enceintes internationale alors qu'on
saura qu'il a été nommé par le Président
de la République et qu'il a même pas eu
un contact avec la représentation
nationale si c'est la formule que vous
choisissez il expédiera les affaires
courantes c'estàd qu'il règle les petits
problèmes du quotidien il ne peut
prendre aucune décision importante
engageant la France Monsieur mitant
souhaite répondre sur ce point monsieur
bar que vous avez nommé a mis 41 jours à
se présenter devant la l'Assemblée
nationale je va dire par là que pendant
41 jours il a bien fallu qu'il fasse
quelque chose non ah il n'a rien fait il
il a il a géré les affaires courantes
c'est une tradition monsieurant et çael
veut dire dans ce cas-là c'est un point
important que votre dissolution elle ne
pourra intervenir que mi- juuin ou fin
juin parce que si vous regardez le
calendrier comme je l'ai fait avec soin
vous savez que l'installation du nouveau
président de la République se fait un
jour près il y a un petit problème de en
discussion vers le 25 ou 26 mai qui est
l'anniversaire de ma prise de fonction
et la convocation de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est début juin il y a
quelques jours nécessaires d'autant plus
que c'est la sension à ce moment-là le
gouvernement va devant l'Assemblée
nationale s'il met du temps à y aller
comme l'avait fait monsieur bar ça veut
dire que votre dissolution peut
intervenir qu'à la mi-juin et que donc
les Français voteront à la mi-juillet ou
fin juuillet est réaliste le président
de la République peut dissoudre quand il
le veut et je dissoudrai quand je le
déciderai et à ce moment-là je ne serai
pas pas dans l'obligation de vous rendre
compte j'agirai selon mes devoirs et la
Constitution croyez-moi elle sera
respectée j'ai l'intention de dissoudre
et j'ai l'intention de faire procéder à
des élections avant le 1er juillet s'il
y a un argument majeur s'opposit à cela
de toute manière ma décision serait
maintenue je veux dire par là que je ne
serait pas en mesure de garder cette
assemblée et le problème pour moi serait
de disposer d'une majorité parce qu'on
ne peut pas mener une autre politique
sans une autre majorité quant au délis
monsieur giscardestin je verrai bien
mais supposons que il y ait la moindre
raison qui puisse mêre objecter par
d'autres juristes que par vous comme je
suis né légaliste je le resterai cela ne
m'empêchera pas élu président de la
République de mener la politique que
j'entendrai mener bien entendu avec le
Parlement dès qu'il sera là ou vous êtes
bien changeant monsieurérant parce qu' y
a quelques instants vous nous aviez dit
que saviez pas si vous disouderiez tout
de suite que vous étiez prêt à voir si
sur un sujet tel que par exemple la loi
électorale le Parlement ne pourrait pas
plus ou moins en délibérer puis vous
revenez tout à coup en arrière vous
dites je dissoudrai tout de suite et
même avec une précipitation très grande
car si vous voulez faire les élections
avant la fin du mois de juin il faut que
le premier acte de votre septena soit la
dissolution vous n'avez pas le temps
d'aller devant le Parlement étudier le
problème et donc vous prendrez en
arrivant un décret de dissolution vous
ferez donc ce qu'a fait j'ad Mac
c'està-dire que sans avoir que sans
avoir rencontré la représentation
nationale sans même qu'un gouvernement
sohait aller lui dire voilà mon
programme vous direz Messieurs les
Députés je vous renvoie chez vous ce qui
veut dire d'ailleurs que les conditions
de l'élection et la signification pour
le président de la République seront
très fortes car si vous renvoyez les
députés sans même qu'ils aient eu droit
à un exposé de la politique de votre
gouvernement et la possibilité
d'exprimer la censure ensuite si le
souvrage universel R voit les mêmes
c'est un des aveux au président de la
République il ne faut pas confondre avec
la situation de 78 dont nous avions
débattu quand il y a une élection
normale en France si elle envoie une
majorité différente le président de la
République doit en tirer un certain
nombre de conséquences il doit avec
sagesse essayer de trouver une formule
mais si le président de la République
prend l'initiative et vous venez de le
dire de renvoyer la représentation
parlementaire sans même la réunir et si
la même représentation parlementaire
revient quelle est l'autorité quelle est
situation du président de la République
et en tout cas dans l'intervalle dans
l'intervalle le gouvernement ainsi formé
ne peut qu'expédier les affaires
courantes il ne peut entreprendre aucune
des grandes actions ou aucune des
grandes décisions que vous avez évoqué
dans vos déclarations récent monsieur
liscardestin en ce qui concerne
l'expédition des affaires courantes je
voudrais que vous puissiez préciser avec
Monsieur mitteran des points trois
points précis parce que Monsieur Marchet
a déclaré au lendemain du Comité central
du Parti communiste qu'il attendait d'un
gouvernement de gauche trois mesures
précises la hausse du SMIC le blocage
des prix la revalorisation des
allocations familiales est-ce que sur
ces trois mesures précises un
gouvernement ne peut pas agir sans avoir
recours à l'Assemblée
nationale je ne voudrais pas si vous
permettez que nous passions notre temps
à vous comporter en juriste compliqué
discutant de choses que beaucoup de
français risquent de ne pas aimer dans
la mesure où ça les ennuiera je suis
quelqu'un qui a toujours respect la loi
et je la respecterai j'ajoute que comme
vous serez à ce moment-là ancien
président de la République vous ferez
partie du comité constitutionnel et vous
pourrez dire votre du Conseil
constitutionnel et vous pourrez dire
votre
mot sur le TR sur les trois problèmes
que je viens d'évoquer est-ce que les
décisions peuvent être pris sans
l'accord du Parlement et est-ce que vous
les prendriez plusieurs de ces mesures
sont d'ordre
réglementaire c'est-à-dire sont de
l'autorité du gouvernement nous les
retrouverons tout à l'heure le
gouvernement c'est toujours mais nous
somm toujours le gouvernement de la
République toujours ce sont des points
très importantsallons pas y rester j'ai
des questions plus importantes encore à
vous poser mais ce sont les questions
importantes car il ne faut pas faire
croire aux Français que vous aurez le
pouvoir de prendre en mai ou en juin des
décisions que vous ne pourrez pas
prendre parce que légalement vous ne
pourrez pas le prendre quand vous dites
par exemple je baisserai la TVA sur les
produits de consommation courante vous
n'aurez pas le droit de le faire oui
mais peer le
SMIC le SMIC on peut le fixer et on peut
bloquer les prix et c'est à la
limite jamais pris dans des périodes qui
ne sont que des périodes électorales des
décisions qui bouleversent les
conditions de l'activité c'est contraire
à la coutume mais ce n'est pas contraire
à la contraire à la coutume et une
décision de cette nature serait
d'ailleurs très vivement critique alors
deuxème question à Monsieur bteran il y
a donc des élections si comme vous le
dites vous renvoyez l'Assemblée
nationale c'est parce que vous voulez
avoir une autre majorité et cette autre
majorité on voit bien de qui elle est
composée elle est composé des 26 % des
lecteurs que vous avez eu dont
d'ailleurs quelques points de communiste
et puis il faut trouver 24 ou 25 autres
donc la totalité de l'électorat
communiste comme nous avons esruté un
arrondissement de tour vous revenez de
dire à l'instant que vous dissolviez
tout de suite donc il n'y a pas de
changement doie électoral il faut un
accord électoral vous NZ pas le faire
avec ceux que vous avez chassé vous le
ferez donc avec ceux qui vouslez ramener
c'est-à-dire avec le Parti communiste
quelles sont les conditions que le Parti
communiste vous demandera pour aboutir à
un tel accord électoral et deuxièmement
quand vous aurez nommé vot Premier
ministre ensuite et qu'il viendra vous
dire Monsieur le Président de la
République voilà la liste des ministres
et je vous propose des ministres
communistes quelle sera votre
réponse j'ai déjà
répondu au premiè élément de la question
posée non pas spécialement par vous mais
par l'opinion publique que j'ai souvent
entendu poser tout le long de cette
campagne j'ai d'ailleurs eu l'occasion
d'y répondre au cours des multiples
débats qui m'ont conduit au postes de
télévision ou au postees de
radiodiffusion et j'ai dit ce que je
répète car j'ai déjà abordé de moi-même
ce sujet que le premier gouvernement que
je constiurai sera composé des femmes et
des hommes qui se seront engagés sur les
options du candidat des socialistes que
je suis toujours bien entendu à partir
du moment où les élections législatives
devront être préparées il appartiendra
aux organisations politiques
responsables vous savez que les partis
politiques existent ont des droits sont
reconnus par la Constitution à son
article 4 même quand le président de la
République met gravement en cause et ces
organisations politiques se
rencontreront discuteront est-ce que les
partis de gauche notamment socialistes
et communistes seront en mesure
d'aboutir c'est-à-dire à signer un
accord de
gouvernement à s'entendre pour la
suite je le saurai à ce moment-là est-ce
qu'ils auront réussi à vaincre les
obstacles qui les ont dominés en 1977
c'est cette discussion sérieuses qu'il
faut engager que j'ai toujours souhaité
en tant que responsable du parti
socialiste hier donc cette discussion
aura lieu les organisations politiques
décideront souverainement elles-mêmes de
ce qu'elles doit faire c'est-à-dire de
leurs accords ou de leur désaccords et
si elles sont d'accord il appartiendra
aux Français de choisir c'est-à-dire que
ce sont les Français qui auront le
dernier mot puisqu'ils voteront pour
l'élection des députés à ce moment-là je
pourrais vous apporter la réponse mais
je voudrais vous dire à moins que vous
n'ayez déjà des objections faire sur ce
sujet que
cette question sans cesse posée donc
j'aperçois bien pourquoi elle est je
trouve ça très intéressant parce que moi
j'ai l'inttion de parler de façon très
claire vous savez très claire cela fait
déjà très longtemps que je me suis battu
dans ce pays pour tenter de réussir
l'union de la gauche et je n'ai jamais
désavoué ma démarche simplement je me
suis trouvé devant une situation qui la
rendait impossible à partir de là j'ai
dû le constater mais les socialistes
dont je ne suis plus le premier
responsable dont je ne seraiis plus
responsable ni membre mais proche
cependant une fois élu président de la
République ce parti socialiste restera
maître de cette décision et bien entendu
je pense qu'il restera lui aussi fidèle
à l'axe de sa politique qui tente au
rassemblement populaire autour de ses
objectifs voilà ce que j'entends
faire monsieur est-ce Queau fond vous ne
reculez pas pour TER est-ce que cet
accord avec les communistes que vous ne
recherchez pas entre le 1er et le 2è
tour de l'élection présidentielle vous
allez le rechercher dès que l'élection
présidentielle sera terminéad cot ce
n'est pas mon affaire comme candidat à
l'élection présidentielle Vous vous
trompez d'élection vous vous trompez
d'élection il s'agit d'élire un
président de la République il ne s'agit
pas pour l'instant de constituer un
gouvernement sur la base d'une nouvelle
majorité on élira d'abord un président
de la République ce président de la
République ensuite indiquera à quel
moment auront lieu des élections
législatives et ceux qui voudront
constiu une majorité dans un camp comme
dans l'autre se réunieront pour en
discuter voilà et à ce moment-là bien
entendu je tiendrai compte de ce qui
aura été décidé et je verrai bien quelle
majorité aurait été adopté par les
français puisque ce sont les Français
qui décideront j'ai personnellement le
sentiment qu'élu président de la
République c'est-à-dire disposant d'une
majorité la majorité elle se formera le
10 mai cette majorité là elle aura une
force entraînante
formidable ce sera un événement vous
savez pour la France que l'élection d'un
président de la République socialiste et
le rassemblement qui se
constituera nous placera dans une
situation psychologique et politique
différente de celle d'aujourd'hui et
j'espère en effet que ce rassemblement
populaire se constituera et si la
majorité n'est pas conforme à ce que
vous en attendez gouvernerez avec je
suis un démocrate à ce momentlà je
seraiis contraint de répondre comme
monsieur cardestin a Verdin sur le dou
lorsqu'il pouvait redouter la victoire
de la gauche en
1978 j'appliquerai la loi et je resterai
là où je suis en essayant de veiller aux
intérêts de la France de mon mieux
monsieur on ne peut pas défendre des
théories de cette nature je vous dis
très franchement d'abord on peut pas
conduire un peuple les vieux bandés
c'est un peuple majeur qui doit savoir
où il va vous venez de nous dire il y a
quelques minutes que vous prendriez une
décision tout de suite qui était de
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale parce
que vous ne pouvez pas travailler avec
la majorité qui existe que vous avez
qualifié de conservatrice donc vous
renvoyez les députés et vous nous dites
ensuite et bien on verra avec qui on
s'entendra mais on verra pas avec qui
puisque dès lors que la majorité s'en va
vous êtes obligé de rechercher un accord
à l'intérieur de ceux qui vous auront
soutenu c'est-à-dire socialiste et
communiste il aucune autre alternative
et j'imagine qu'à l'heure actuelle vous
y avez réfléchi vous allez pas découvrir
le 15 juin qu'un accord entre les
socialistes et les communistes est
impossible alors qu'on sera au plein
milieu de l'élection que vous aurez
vous-même décidé et deuxièmement vous ne
pouvez pas dire au français je veux
conduire un grand changement avec
n'importe qui c'est ce qui ce que vous
êtes en train de nous dire y compris
même l'assemblée actuelle parce que dans
ce cas-là ne la dissolvez pas et surtout
si vous voulez conduire un grand
changement avec n'importe qui c'est que
vous ne voulez pas conduire un grand
changement parce que vous savez très
bien que le projet socialiste que j'ai
là qui est d'ailleurs un texte important
et dont nous lirons tout à l'heure des
extraits c'est un changement important
de la vie de la France et que la
majorité actuelle non seulement n est
pas favorable mais est absolument
hostile si donc votre projet votre
ambition c'est le projet socialiste ou
une formule voisine il faut avoir une
majorité pour le faire j'imagine pas
l'autorité ni intérieure ni extérieure
du président de la République française
et ça compte j'ai porté le poids de
cette fonction pendant 7 ans je
n'imagine pas son autorité si étant élu
avec les voix communistes il va revenir
après avoir congédier le Parlement une
majorité qui lui soit hostile et qui
disent à ce moment-là mais tout va bien
je continue et je vais diriger les
affaires de la France c'est totalement
un vrai semblable à Verdin sur le dou ce
que j'avais dit c'est que dans une
échéance électorale normale le président
de la République en fonction a le devoir
de tenir compte de ce que choisissent
les électeurs mais s'il prend
l'initiative car c'est vous qui prendz
l'initiative de congédier le Parlement
et si l'opinion publique le désavoue car
c'est ça que ça veut dire en en
renvoyant une majorité de sens inverse
le président de la République n'a plus
aucune autorité et à mon avis il ne peut
pas rester et d'ailleurs à mon avis il
ne resterait pas dans une autre
situation ce serait différent la vérité
c'est que vous avez besoin d'une
majorité pour faire ce que vous voulez
faire et que cette majorité c'est
l'alliance d'ailleurs normale vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure des
communistes et des socialistes mais dans
ce cas-là il faut vous battre
ouvertement pour dire cette majorité il
faut la il faut la rassembler d'abord
lors de l'élection présidentielle et
ensuite lors de l'élection législative
sinon nous entrons dans un système
politique de désordrre de confusion
comme la France en a connu dans le passé
et comme la 5e République heureusement
nous en a délivré messieur je me permets
simplement de vous faire remarquer que
sur cette première partie de votre
discussion il reste à Monsieur mitéran
un peu moins de 3 minutes et à Monsieur
giscardestin un peu moins de 2 minutes
je voudrais
répondre monsieur
giscardestin je souhaite gagner
l'élection
présidentielle je pense la gagner mais
quand je l'aurai gagné je ferai tout ce
qu'il conviendra de faire dans le cadre
de la loi pour gagner les élections
législatives et si vous imaginez pas ce
que sera à partir de lundi prochain
l'état d'esprit de la France sa
formidable volonté de changement alors
c'est que vous ne comprenez rien à ce
qui se passe dans ce
pays et si tous ceux qui veulent se
rassembler autour du président de la
République élu le 10 mai veulent l'aider
par la suite de plus en plus nombreux à
former la majorité législative
elle me trouvera à ses côtés quant à
votre dégagement disons antiommuniste
permettez-moi de vous dire qu'il
mériterait quelques correctifs car c'est
quand même un peu trop
facile comprenez les les travailleurs
communistes sont nombreux on finirait
par croire dans votre raisonnement à
quoi servent-il ils servent à à produire
à travailler ils servent à payer des
impôts ils servent à mourir dans les
guerres ils servent à tout mais ils ne
peuvent jamais servir à faire une
majorité en
France la façon dont vous le dites
implique une sorte d'exclusion de la vie
nationale qui pas dans mon état d'esprit
de telle sorte que si les Français
élisent une majorité lors des élections
législatives qui soit une majorité de
rassemblement populaire bien entendu je
travaillerai avec elle monsieur mitéran
êtes-vous satisfait de voir le score du
Parti communiste au premier tour des
élections présidentielles ramené à 15 %
du corps électoral pardon question
complémentaire à qui de vous deux cela
fait-il le plus plaisir moi je suis
surtout satisfait d'avoir atteint 26 %
et bien entendu quand on gagne des
suffragees on les prend à quelqu'un
d'autre bon donc je n'ai pas passé de
temps à déplorer les difficultés des
autres bien entendu j'ai fait le compte
et je souhaiterais que les forces de la
gauche soient encore plus puissantes et
je pense que des un certain nombre de
femmes et d'hommes qui n'étaient pas
encore des nôtres le 26 avril viendront
nous rejoindre le DISP parce qu'ils
sentent bien que c'est de ce côté-là que
se trouve l'avenir c'est-à-dire le
changement Mons répondre d'abord vous
avez eu 26 % vois pour employer
l'expression d'un journal qui au votre
candidature vous avez donc été désavoué
par 74 % des Français puisquil dit que
moi j'étais désavoué par combien 72 mais
je n'attaque pas du tout l'électorat
communiste en 7 ans Monsieur miteran
j'ai jamais eu un mot désobligeant pour
la classe ouvrière française jamais je
la respecte dans son travail dans son
activité et même dans son expression
politique c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs dans de grande région
industrielle elle m'a placé devant vous
lors des dernières élections mais ce que
je veux simplement dire c'est qu'il faut
il faut que vous annonciez vos couleurs
et moi j'annonce mes couleurs vous venez
de nous dire et j'en prends acte que
vous souhaitez le succès d'une majorité
de socialistes et de communistes lors
des prochaines élections législatives il
faut que les Français le sachent ça
n'est pas du tout faire grillef aux
électeurs de choisir cette majorité il
faut que les Français le sachent parce
que ce que vous appelez le rassemblement
c'est une nébuleuse et cette nébuleuse
il y a un noyau central qu'on connaît
bien c'est l'ancienne union de la gauche
c'est-à-dire l'entente des socialistes
et des communistes et puis alors a
autour il y a la nébuleuse de ce qu'on
peut tromper pendant un certain temps et
je ne veux pas qu'il y ait de français
trompés donc si vous dites que vous
souhaitez le succès d'une majorité de
socialiste et du communiste c'est
parfaitement clair je ne vous en fais
pas le reproche mais je demande que ceci
soit bien entendu et compris par nos
concitoyens vous trompez nos concitoyens
lorsque vous prétendez avoir une
majorité ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
de la pensée exprimé de Monsieur Chirac
au sujet de votre septena la pureté de
ces propos le sentiment de votre échec
et que le changement de politique
nécessaire devrait entraîner un
changement d'homme et donc un changement
de Président permettez-moi de vous dire
que Jacques Chirac en a dit davantage si
l'on peut rendre à ce pays la confiance
et l'espoir fussent au prix de la
défaite du président de la République
vous c'est l'intérêt de la France qui
m'importe et non pas l'intérêt de tel ou
tel homme y compris le mien et c'est
avec cela que vous allez faire une
majorité moi j'entends en effet élu
président de la République entraîner la
majorité des français qui aura voté pour
moi le 10 mai c'est QFD le 10 mai si je
suis élu c'est bien que j'ai la majorité
pardonnez cette vérité de la Palise et
bien toutes celles et tous ceux-là qui
m'auront qui m'auront soutenu oui
j'essaierai de faire avec eux une
majorité pour les législatifs monsieuran
vous avez 17 secondes à récupérer sur la
suite du débat car vous avez légèrement
débordé mais c'est tout à fait concela
puisqu'au total suffit de 20 secondes je
voulais qu'il a un point clair pour
clarifier le débat les Français
attendent des réponses si vous êtes élu
président de la République vous
souhaiterez l'élection d'une majorité
composée de socialistes et de
communistes lors des élections
législatives qu'entraîneront la
dissolution immédiate de l'Assemblée
national je voulais que ce point soit
connu je souhaiterais battre les forces
conservatrices qui ont marqué sous votre
conduite le déclin de la France et bien
nous allons y venir puisque nous
abordons les questions économiques et
que dans ce domaine vous avez chacun un
passé monsieur valerry GIS cardestin a
le passé d'un homme qui a été Président
de la République pendant
et donc un bilan que certains jugent bon
d'autres médiocre voire
désastreux monsieur miteran a le passé
de ses idées de ses alliances et de ses
amis le programme commun de la gauche
pendant un temps le projet socialiste
aujourd'hui et je voulais vous demander
monsieur giscardestin si vous vous
sentez prisonnier des échecs de votre
SEP et Monsieur mitéran si vous vous
sentez prisonnier
des idées que certains ont définis comme
étant des idées collectivistes monsieur
Giscard bon pas simplification abusive
la France a vécu pendant 7 ans une
période de crise mondiale très difficile
j'en ai porté le poids j'en ai porté le
poids j'en assume les responsabilité je
ne ni rien de ce qui a été fait au cours
de cette période qui était vous le savez
monsieur boissona vous l'avez écrit plus
reprises je vous entends une période de
crise la seule question n'est pas de
savoir si la France a pu se soustraire à
la crise elle ne le pouvait pas
j'indique qu'elle ne le peut pas non
plus maintenant la question est de
savoir si elle fait tout ce qu'elle peut
compte tenu de ses ressources et de sa
politique propre et je vous rappelle que
dans cette période de crise le produit
la production française a augmenté plus
que celle de tout autre pays
industrialisé que le niveau de vie le
pouvoir d'achat des Français a progressé
plus que dans n'importe quel autre pays
industrialisé et que malgré la crise
nous avons réalisé des actions de
solidarité envers des catégories
démunies personnes âgées handicapées
travailleurs manuels famille femme seu
donc je considère qu'un pays ce n'est
pas moi qui l'ai fait qu'un pays qui
fait cela pendant une période de crise
la plus forte augmentation de la
production la plus forte augmentation du
niveau de vie et un effort de solidarité
il a montré ce dont il était capable il
y a deux grands rever de grandes
difficultés la hausse des prix et le
chômage et nous avons entrepris dans ce
domaine des actions vous savez qu'à
l'heure actuelle la hausse des prix
reste trop forte en France mais qu'elle
diminue et je suis convaincu que le
programme tel que je l'ai lu posé par
Monsieur mitteran relancerait
immédiatement l'inflation à la hausse
des prix tout prêt à en débattre et
d'autre part en matière de chômage nous
avons entrepris une action depuis
plusieurs années cette action peut se
développer j'en ai indiqué les modalités
et les conditions donc je prends la
responsabilité de ce qui a été fait je
me fuis aucune responsabilité j'indique
seulement que les efforts que nous avons
accomplis seraient compromis excusezmi
ruinés si le programme tel qu'il est
présenté par Monsieur miteran entit en
application l'été prochain monsieur
mitteran vous êtes Pr on des idées
socialistes en la matière mais je dois
quand même répondre à ce qui a été dit
par monsieurardestin avant de développer
ma propre sans quoi on risque de
s'embouiller je tiens simplement à dire
monsieuricardestin que vous vous êtes
toujours trompé on ne peut plus vous
croire j'ai encore des questions à vous
poser et je voudrais comme je l'ai fait
tout à l'heure expliquez-moi
expliquez-nous je veux dire expliquez au
français et aux Français qui nous
écoutent lorsque vous disiez en
74 je prendrai c'est dura l'État au
moment des promesses des promesses
électorales je prendrai toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour garantir votre
emploi à vous salariés à vous
travailleurs à vous ouvriers et aussi
pour garantir votre revenu à vous
épargnant à vous
agriculteurs lorsque vous disiez
toujours pendant votre septena en 78
c'est grâce à cet effort le vôtre que la
France n'est pas comme d'autres pays sur
la voie d'un accroissement du chômage
mais qu'au contraire elle a pu entamer
une réduction significative du nombre
des demire d'emploi c'était le 26
janvier 1978 à os lorsque vous disiez
dans le même discours l'emploi en
particulier celui des jeunes ne cesse de
s'améliorer on nous prédisait 1 million
et demi de chômeurs ils seront bientôt
moins d'un million on en compte
aujourd'hui
1700000 lorsque vous disiez un certain
nombre de signes qui ne trompe pas
montre que le creux de la vague est
derrière nous le 4 décembre
1975 vous vous êtes toujours trompés et
comment imaginez que vous pourriez faire
demain si vous étiez réélu ce que vous
n'avez pas su faire au cours d'un
premier septena C ans c'est long ça
permet de faire beaucoup de choses et
d'ailleurs monsieur Chirac c'est la fin
de mes citations toujours expliquez-moi
comment vous pourriez faire une majorité
dans ces conditions avec le RPR monsieur
shirac déclaré le 2 février 1979 nos
performances économiques dont vous
parissiez tout à l'heure si satisfait
nos performances économiques sur tous
les points sont très médiocres sur ce
point je me je ne me dissocie pas de
monsieur miteran qui fait la même
analyse et le même
diagnostic alors je termine sur ce sujet
en disant que j'ai là un texte qui été
publié par la fédération patronale
française de la métalurgie dans son
mensuel social international et qui dit
que au championnat du monde de
l'économie parmi les 15 principaux pays
industriels la France se situe en 13e
rang cela n'est pas la preuve d'une très
grande
réussite maintenant question m'est posée
sur le collectivisme non non maintenant
je va je vais répondre d'une phrase oui
ouiond après cette charpr très bien vous
me faites penser au mot de Rivarol c'est
un terrible avantage de n'avoir rien
fait mais il ne faut pas en abuser en
effet vous gérez le ministère de la
parole ceci depuis 1965 ou depuis 1974
moi j'ai géré la France vous faites
d'abondantes citations de Jacques Chirac
pourquoi ne citez-vous pas une seule
fois le nom de Monsieur Marchet depuis
le début de cette émission ce serait
plus intéressant il apporterait des
éléments plus proches de votre analyse
et concernant les performances
économiques j'ai eu l'occasion de
répondre à un président de la République
il doit entraîner son pays il ne doit
pas le décourager il est donc naturel
qu'à tout moment il cherche à lui
proposer des objectifs de redressement
ou d'amélioration s'il fallait rentrer
dans le détail nous ne le ferons pas je
vous rappellerai que ce que je disais en
1978 était exact il y a eu deux chocs
pétrolierers monsieur n'explique pas
tout mais ils ont ébranlé notre économie
le premier a eu lieu en 7374 et nous
commencions à en sortir dans les années
77- 78 monsieur boisson je vous prends
un témoin nous avions à l'époque une
diminution en effet légère du chômage la
hausse des prix était tombée au-dessous
de 10 % nous avions une croissance
supérieure à 3 % par an nous étions en
train Deen sortir vous savez sans doute
qu'il a eu un second choc pétrolier à la
suite des événements d'Iran et ceci à
partir de la MI79 et qui a relancé à
nouveau toutes les difficultés
économiques et le chômage et je me suis
efforcé face au premier et face au
second de Red
la situation de la France nous avons
obtenu un premier redressement dans les
années 77 78 il est incontestable nous
sommes actuellement à l'heure actuelle
en train de nous dégager lentement du
second choc pétrolier j'avais des
résultats aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la
balance des paiement de la France pour
le premier trimestre de 81 et un net
progrès par rapport à 1980 donc ne
recherchons pas les citations du passé
dans lequel vous complaisez Jeuris pas
la cruauté de vous relire ce que vous
disiez quand vous appeliez à la ré du
programme commun avant 1978 ou lorsque
vous opposiez la Constitution de 1958
dont vous cherchez être maintenant le
président de la République donc ceci
c'est le passé nous devons éclairer les
Français sur ce que nous allons faire
nos choix pour l'avenir j'ai proposé un
problème un programme pour l'emploi
critiquéle mais nous ne jouons pas à ce
petit jeu des citation peut-être
qu'avant de venir à l'emploi nous
pouvons demander à Monsieur miteran de
répondre à la critique de ceux qui lui
reproche d'être prisonnier soit encore
du programme commun ou tout au moins de
sa philosophie qu'il croit retrouver
dans le projet socialiste et je prends
un seul exemple celui des
nationalisations parce que c'est celui
qui est le plus public est-ce que vous
avez toujours le programme de
nationalisation est-ce que vous pensez
que ça résoudra le problème des
entreprises que vous entendez
nationaliser et comment serait indemnisé
les propriétaires actuels de ces
entreprises vous ne voulez pas parler du
passé je comprends bien naturellement
euh et vous avez tendance un peu à
reprendre le refrain d'il y a 7 ans
l'homme du passé c'est quand même en que
dansinval vous soyez devenu vous l'homme
du passif cela gêne un peu votre
démonstration d'aujourd'hui vous m'avez
reproché d'avoir exercé une sorte de
ministère de la parole mais moi j'étais
dans l'opposition j'ai rempli mon rôle
démocratiquement dans l'opposition
qu'est-ce que voulez que je fasse
d'autre et l'opposition ce n'est pas
rien dans une république j'ajoute que
j'ai utilisé ce temps pour faire avec
d'autres un grand parti qui est devenu
un parti menaçant pour la majorité
presque ancienne que vous représentez
aujourd'hui donc j'ai pas perdu mont
temps et si je pouvais faire pour la
France demain à la mesure de la France
bien entendu ce que j'ai pu faire pour
le socialisme en France ma fois ce ne
serait pas perdu les deux chocs
pétroliers c'est vrai bien entendu c'est
pas la peine de prendre un T professoral
pour dire on l'a remarqué figurez-vous
qu'on l'a remarqué nous aussi qu' y
avait de chocs pétroliers et je ne suis
pas de ceux qui ont dire que le coût du
pétrole ne compte pas et lourdement dans
les difficultés qui sont nôtres mais
tout rejeté sur le pétrole ce n'est pas
vrai
ceou mais la part est plus grande encore
que celle que vous entendiez sur le plan
de l'inflation le pétrole pèse lourd
mais disons 3 % sur les presque 14 % de
l'année
1980 de telle sorte qu'il faut que vous
vous expliquer aussi le faire dans les 3
jours qui restent sur votre
responsabilité dans la vie chère en
France mais j'en reviens maintenant à la
question que vous m'avez posé après
avoir simplement fait remarquer que la
Grande-Bretagne qui produit du pétrole
et dans une grave crise et que le Japon
qui n'en produit pas supporte très bien
le choc de la concurrence internationale
ce qui démolit pour une part le
raisonnement de Monsieur vous interrompr
un mot simplement l'Angleterre n'arrive
pas à se remettre des conséquences de la
gestion travailliste c'est-à-dire
socialiste dont elle a souffert pendant
5 ans et le Japon au contraire stimulé
par son économie libérale est en effet
capable de se dégager du choc pétrolier
ce n'est pas exact du tout la crise avec
commen avec les conservateurs et les
deux pays qui en Europe s'entirent le
mieux aujourd'hui sont un pays à gestion
socialiste l'Autriche et un pays qui
dont la gestion socialiste fut si longue
qu'elle pèse encore sur les décisions du
gouvernement qui leura succédé je veux
dire la Suède mais on ne va pas
s'attarder sur cette discussion nos
auditeurs concluront demain ce que je
veux dire c'est que pour ce qui concerne
le programme commun et la liste des
nationalisations qui figureent bien
entendu elle se trouve un peu euh
contredite par l'événement dans la
mesure où vous le savez certain nombre
de de ces sociétés que l'on ne voulait
pas que je nationalise ont été dans
l'intervalle internationalisé par le
grand capital je pense en particulier à
rousse à luclla fait à certaines
branches et ça c'est un problème très
actuel de péchiné mais la liste en
question reste la liste que je retiens
en effet je compte
nationaliser les les banques ce qui
reste non nationalisé depuis la
nationalisation des banques exécutées
par toutes les banques monsieur mil les
banques les banques toutes les banques
euh le général de le général de GA avait
fait l'essentiel en 1945 il avait
regretté en 1947 de ne pas avoir tout
fait et bien il m'incomberra de le faire
à mon tour et 11 je crois groupes
industriels ce que j'entends dire c'est
que la liste que j'ai déjà produite
c'est à valeur de contrat ce qui veut
dire que qui n'est pas dans cette liste
ne sera pas nationalisé si plus tard il
devait y avoir des évolutions il y en
aura c'est-à-dire de nouvelles
concentrations capitalistes tendant au
monopole dans les secteurs clés de
l'économie alors il
appartiendra à au Parlement lors de
futures élections c'est-à-dire lorsque
les Français seront en mesure de
souscrire un nouveau contrat avec les
responsables politiques mais tant que je
serai responsable dans la situation
présente la liste est une liste
limitative monsieur mit m'autorisez-Vous
une question plus personnelle je vous en
prie est-ce que quand vous dites c'est
un contrat je le respecte vous voulez
signifier par là qu'il y a des symboles
en politique qui ont leur importance et
qu'il faut savoir plier à ces symboles
telle ou telle appréciation
d'opportunité que l'on peut avoir
autrement dit êtes-vous vous au fond de
vous-même convaincu qu'en faisant cela
pour résolver des problèmes de la France
ou convaincu qu'en faisant cela vous
créez un symbole autour duquel vous
pouvez réunir des forces qui permettront
de résoudre d'autres problèmes non
monsieur boisson je suis convaincu que
le gouvernement de la France aura le
plus grand besoin pour conduire
l'économie d'un vaste secteur public qui
déjà aujourd'hui est la véritable
locomotive de l'investissement et de
l'exportation en France et lorsqu'il y a
lorsqu'il y a les secteurs importants où
la concurrence a cessé d'exister
c'estàdire où le grand capital est
dévorer les petites et moyennes
entreprises je pense qu'il appartient à
la nation d'intervenir monsieur
jiscardestin pour en arriver au problème
de l'emploi vous avez dit et vous avez
redit tout à l'heure que c'était à vos
yeux un échec du SEPA alors vous avez
rendu public un plan pour l'emploi mais
en essayant de le résumer tout à l'heure
avec Jean boissena on avait l'impression
que vous déplacez les emplois que vous
les aménagez en quelque sorte mais que
vous n'en créez pas de nouveau est-ce
que vous pouvez me dire si nous nous
trompons vous trompez naturellement tout
à fait je reviens en arrière pour noter
il faut noter les points forts de ce
débat les nationalisation donc monsieur
miteran s'il était élu président de la
République fera nationaliser l'ensemble
du système bancaire et 11 grands groupes
industriels c'est un point très
important j'ai fait vérifier ce que cela
représente cela veut dire que dans
l'industrie française il y aura 50 %
d'industrie nationalisée la France sera
nationalisée pour la moitié de son
industrie il n'y a aucun pays d'Europe
aucun pays occidental qui aura une telle
structure je le dis pour les
téléspectateurs parce que il croit que
la gestion de Monsieur miteran serait
apporterait quelques modification àel à
quelques conditions de vie pas du tout
nous serions dans une économie
socialisée à partir du moment où tout le
système du crédit est un système
étatique où la moitié d' l'activité
industrielle est étatique c'est une
économie socialisée il faut le savoir et
ça permet de répondre à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure de Jacques Chirac
Monsieur litérant Jacques Chirac nous
écoutant vous écoutant et ayant
enregistré au cours de sa campagne au
contraire l'appel à la liberté d'une
grande partie du secteur productif
français notamment les petites et
moyennes entreprises et entendant cette
socialisation du crédit et et de la
moitié de l'industrie française est en
effet porté par un mouvement spontané à
soutenir celui qui défend la conception
de de liberté dans la vie économique ce
point là aussi le premier point tout à
l'heure était politique ce point je
crois qu'il faut que les Français le
connaissent je ne vous en fais pas Grif
je vous ferai contraire Grif qu'il resta
dans l'ombre à l'heure actuelle on sait
ce sera une société plus bureaucratique
la moitié de l'industrie française sera
étatisée car c'est cela la
nationalisation la totalité du système
du crédit sera également étatisé al je
vous pose une question par rapport à
l'indépendance pétrolière tout à l'heure
pourquoi voulez-vous arrêter le
programme électronucléaire
français beaucoup de questions à la fois
il y a pas de question prenez acte dans
le début si vous voulez bien y revenir
tout à l'heure mais je voudrais qu'on
procède par ordre oui nous pension y
revenir quand voulez qu'on parle de
l'emploi peut-être que nous reviendrons
sur les problèmes énergéti bon on
reviendra sur les problèmes énergétiques
et je préciserai d'ailleurs ma question
alors nous Pons pas commenter un un
dispositif général pour l'emploi
qu'est-ce que j'ai quelle a été le point
central de mon dispositif c'est qu'il
arrive à l'heure actuelle 750000 jeunes
sur le marché du travail en France que
cette arrivée des jeunes n'est pas
l'unique cause mais est un
facteur de déséquilibre de notre marché
du travail et qu'il faut donc offrir des
emplois à la totalité des emplois ou des
formations à la totalité des jeunes
Français qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail comment fa c'est très différent
offrir des emplois ou des formations
parce que si vous offrez des formations
au bout desquelles il n'y a pas d'emploi
ce n'est pas du tout la même non j'ai
dit des emplois ou des ou des formations
ce qui assure pour un jeune le fait que
ou bien il travaille ou bien il est en
formation et pendant ce temps le
développement d'activité économique ou
la reconquête de certains secteurs du
travail j'ai je suis le seul à avoir
parler problème de l'immigration en
France permet de restituer ensuite des
emplois aux jeunes Français en fin de
formation lorsque j'ai été élu président
de la République il y avait encore un
grand nombre de jeunes Français qui
arrivaient sur le marché du travail sans
formation ce nombre a été réduit de de
plus de moitié à l'URE actuelle de 95000
et l'objectif que j'ai indiqué c'est de
le ramener à zéro l'expérience montre
que les jeunes Français et les jeunes
Français lorsqu'ils ont un degré de
formation suffisant et lorsqu'il y a une
bonne orientation des circuits de
formation trouent des emplois dans des
conditions meilleures donc c'est un plan
cohérent qui repose sur un certain
nombre de mesures de mise à la retraite
mais la différence de celle que propose
monsieur miteran qui sont générales par
abaissement des limites d'âge ce sont au
contraire des possibilités ouvertes par
voie conventionnelle parce que je
considère que d'ici quelques années la
situation du marché de l'emploi sera
différente en France à partir des années
85 et qu'il faut garder une grande
souplesse pour que les Français puissent
avoir une liberté d'appréciation
concernant l'âge de la retraite donc il
y aura un effort de formation
professionnelle un certain nombre de
possibilités ouvertes concernant des
possibilités de retraite par
anticipation dans la fonction publique
possibilité de retraite par anticipation
pour créer des recrutements mais sans
augmenter le nombre total de
fonctionnaires et enfin stimulation de
l'activité économique dans un certain
nombre de secteurs de pointe ce que nous
avons déjà fait pour aboutir à la
création d'emploi nouveaux monsieur
mitéran vous avez vous aussi vos projets
en matière d'emploi et peut-être
voulez-vous réagir à celui de Monsieur
giscarist il faut que je revienne un peu
en arrière et d'autre part je dispose
d'un crédit de temps assez mince donc je
vais être obligé de parler en langage un
peu schématique j'espère que vous me le
pardonnez nationalisation je rappellerai
que c'est le général de Gaulle qui a
nationalisé en
1945 l'essentiel de ce qui est
aujourd'hui
nationalis société nationale charbonage
électricité gaz Renault assurance banque
banque de
dépôt je rappellerai que un pays comme
le Portugal a nationalisé les banques et
ce n'est pas un pays socialiste je
dirais également que si l'on compare
l'état des nationalisations en en
Autriche et en Italie avec ce qui existe
en France on aurait des surprises je
voudrais enfin rappeler mais ça nous
lancerait dans une discussion d'école
qui serait un peu compliquée qu'en
France c'est la gauche en effet qui
nationalise lorsque c'est nécessaire
pour défendre les intérêts des petites
et moyennes entreprises du marché la
concurrence contre la toutpuissance de
quelques groupes nationaux ou
internationaux mais c'est la droite qui
étatise nous n'étatisons pas la
bureaucratie c'est vous qui l'avez faite
d'ailleurs c'est vous qui gouvernez si
vous vous plaignez aujourd'hui dans aux
homélies de toutes les mefet de
l'administration et la bureaucratie d'où
est-ce que ça vient c'est vous qui
gouvernez donc c'est vous qui êtes
responsable vous vous tapez sur la
poitrine à 3 jours naturellement d'une
élection je comprends pourquoi vous le
faites mais qu'est-ce qui me laisserait
penser que pendant les 7 ans qui
viendrai vous feriez autrement que ce
que vous avez fait pendant 7 ans gardons
dans ce débat le temps qui convient je
garde le temps et je les observations
pas par rapport à vous je vous en prie
c'est contenu de la même façon et
j'entends m'exprimer absolument comme je
le veux et je le ferai dans des termes
tout à fait corrects à votre égard sauf
que lorsqu'il s'agit de parler de notre
débat politique je n'entends pas être
complaisant maintenant vous voulez
parler vous m'avez parlé vousmême de
l'emploi 1700000 chômeurs demandeur
d'emploi je sais bien la distinction
sémantique qui permet d'éviter les mots
qui brûle la bouche mais le chômage et
les ressenti comme le chômage et non pas
comme la demande d'emploi par les
millions et les millions de gens qui
nous entend chômeur
1700000 on nous en promet ce sont les
experts 2 500000 si votre politique
continue pour les années prochaines
d'ici à
1985 c'est une association d'économistes
qui disait que nous aurions 500000
chômeurs de plus dans les années
prochaines et vous savez très bien que
c'est également l'opinion du grand
patronat français si je j'en juge par
les dernières déclarations du CNPF si
cette politique continue nous aurons au
moins 2500000 chômeurs et vous n'avez
pas agi contre cela vous l'avez accepter
c'est même la plaie de votre expérience
et de votre subtenat non seulement vous
avez considéré au fond que le salaire et
le salarié c'était l'ennemi que l'on
pouvait lutter contre l'inflation à la
condition de tenir le salaire et vous
n'yêtes pas parvenu vous avez eu et
l'inlation et le chômage mais en plus
c'est la tare c'est la maladie et c'est
une maladie qui risque d'être mortelle
pour notre société 60 % des chômeurs
sont des
femmes la plupart des chômeurs non
disait sont des jeunes c'est un mal
immense et on fait des statistiques ici
on pourrait établir des pourcentages
dans la réalité c'est la vie quotidienne
c'est une atteinte dramatique à la
dignité de l'homme et de la femme ceux
qui n'osent même pas dire pourquoi on
les rejette ils éprouvent une sorte de
honte d'ailleurs ils se trompent il ne
devrait pas éprouver cela mais ils ont
le sentiment d'être des exclus et quand
on parle de la démoralisation de la
France il faut comprendre que le chômage
est la raison principale de cette
démoralisation voilà pourquoi je pense
monsieurestin que l'axe principal de
toute politique doit aujourd'hui tourner
autour de la des solutions à apporter au
chômage et aucune de vos réponses ne
peut nous satisfaire c'est la reprise
comme ça à distance de tout ce que vous
disiez déjà en 1974 moi j'ai parlé de
problème précis j'ai parl de la
réduction du temps de travail j'ai parlé
des 35 heures hebdomadaires qui devront
être négociés par les partenaires
sociaux lo progressivement je j'entends
d'abord en débattre avec les partenaires
sociaux dont j'ai dit que je les
rencontrerai aussitôt que je seraiis élu
président de la République entreprise
par entreprise s'il le faut mais branche
par branche en tout cas je pense qu'il
était plus simple d'adopter la retraite
à 60 ans naturellement facultative et
volontaire comme je le demande depuis si
longtemps plutôt que d'imposer la
préretraite car en réalité comment ça se
passe dans nos villages et dans nos
villes c'est imposé la prèretraite le
patronat fait savoir que si l'on veut
ramasser les miettes il faut partir tout
de suite alors on obtiendra quand même
quelque chose la prèretraite est une
imposition c'est c'est une contrainte
j'ai également évoqué une politique de
grands travaux une politique d'aide aux
petites entreprises et moyennes pour le
développement de la main d'œuvre
naturellement il faut aussi soutenir
l'agriculture et le commerce si on veut
pas que leurs enfants leurs filles et
leurs garçons viennent grossir le lot du
chômage bien entendu il faut s'attaquer
s'attaquer à la formation
professionnelle et je vais dire
simplement à ce sujet en vous disant que
pour ce qui concerne la formation
professionnelle il y a une loi crois
qu'elle date de 1971 qui permet sur le
plan de la formation continue c'est un
élément important la formation
professionnelle de d'aller jusqu'à 2 %
de de du total des salaires d'une
entreprise sous forme de taxe pour
disposer du moyen de développer la
formation on en est à 1,1 c'est-à-dire
que le gouvernement n'a pas fait
l'effort qu'il fallait pour inviter les
entreprises à respecter la loi j'arrête
là parce que nous avons besoin
naturellement d'échanger les propos et
que le temps passe revendrai dans un
momentpp je vous rappelle qu' en ce
moment précis monsieur muérant vous
n'avez plus que moins de 3 minutes
monsieur gescardestin vous avez environ
7 minutes oui alors monsieur mitéran a
parlé avec émotion et je le comprends
c'est la la même que lui du problème du
chômage il en a parlé j'ai agi il y a
plusieurs années que nous travaillons
sur ce problème et nous avons pris un
certain nombre d'initiatives peut-être
que monsieur miteran n'a pas entendu
parler des pactes nationaux pour
l'emploi il en a eu trois successifs
auxquels ont été associés les
entreprises et les syndicats et qui ont
permis de placer de nombreux jeunes
d'autre part il faut savoir qu'il y a un
grand mouvement sur le marché du travail
en France il faut pas présenter la
situation du chômage comme étant une
situation statique je vous indique que
dans les 12 mois de 1980
2829000 demandes d'emploi ont été
satisfaites
2829000 en 12 mois ce qui prouve la le
grand mouvement qu'il y a en matière de
marché du travail en France alors moi je
vous dis une chose tout à fait simple
mon si vous êtes élu le chômage
augmentera vous faites allusion à des
études de je ne sais qui d'ailleurs des
experts il tour des experts pour faire
des pronostics dans un sens ou dans
l'autre on l'a vu jusqu' compris dans
les sondages électoraux d'ailleurs moi
je vous dis ceci très simplement si vous
êtes élu le chage j'augmentera pourquoi
à cause des mesures que vous prendrez
parce que vous avez dit d'abord que vous
prendrez rapidement une mesure
concernant l'augmentation des salaires
l'augmentation du SM vous savez quel est
l'état actuel de la situation des
petites et moyennes entreprises elles ne
sont pas en état de supporter des
charges supplémentaires et donc les
petits employeurs les petits patrons au
quel on dira on major votre SMIC de le
CH changé
combien le SMIC à combien P ça reste à
discuter j'ai pendant tout le long de ma
campagne que si le gouvernement avait
comme c'est la loi autorité pour décid
SMIC je ne voulais pas me passer de la
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales ça dans le projet socialiste
il y a un chiffre qui figure et ce
chiffre comme vous le savez donne une
augmentation hors augmentation des prix
qui est de l'ordre de 30 à 33 % hors
augmentation des prix ce qui veut dire
pour l'année contenu de l'augmentation
des prix quelque chose de 40 à 43 %
d'augmentation du SP les petites
entreprises auxquelles ceci sera imposé
seront hors des cas de recruter
deuxièmement vous avez dans votre projet
je donne lecture le fait que le comité
d'entreprise disposera dans certain a un
grand mouvement sur le marché du travail
en France il faut pas présenter la
situation du chômage comme étant une
situation statique je vous indique que
dans les 12 mois de 1980
2829000 demandes d'emploi ont été
satisfaites
2829000 en 12 mois ce qui prouve le
grand mouvement qu'il y a en matière de
marché du travail en France alors moi je
vous dis une chose tout à fait simple
si vous êtes élu le chômage augmentera
vous faites allusion à des études de je
ne sais qui d'ailleurs des experts il t
des experts pour faire des pronostics
dans un sens ou dans l'autre on l'a vu
jusqu'auuss compris dans les sondages
électoraux d'ailleurs moi je vous dis
ceci très simplement si vous êtes élu le
chômage augmentera pourquoi à cause des
mesures que vous prendrez parce que vous
avez dit d'abord que vous prendrez
rapidement une mesure concernant
l'augmentation des salaires
l'augmentation du schi vous savez quel
est l'état actuel de la situation des
petites et moyennes entreprises elles ne
sont pas en état de de supporter des
charges supplémentaires et donc les
petits employeurs les petits patrons au
quel on dira au major votre SMIC de le
chire a changé combien monsie le SMIC à
combien pense ça reste à discuter j'ai
pendant tout le long de ma campagne
indiqué que si le gouvernement avait
comme c'est la loi autorité pour décid
SMIC je ne voulais pas me passer de la
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales ça dans le projet socialiste
il y a un chiffre qui figure et ce
chiffre comme vous le savez donne lieu
une augmentation hors augmentation des
prix qui est de l'ordre de 30 à 33 %
hors augmentation des prix ce qui veut
dire pour l'année compenu de
l'augmentation des prix quelque chose de
40 à 43 % d'augmentation du SM les
petites entreprises auxquelles ceci sera
imposé seront hors d'état de recruter
deuxièmement vous avez dans votre projet
je donne lecture le fait que le comité
d'entreprise disposera dans certains
domaines d'un droit de veto et notamment
les décisions d'embauche et de
licenciement cell con concernant
l'organisation du travail le la
formation le plan de formation de
l'entreprise entre en particulier dans
cette catégorie où le comité
d'entreprise aura droit de veto et vous
allez plus loin page page 242 et
243 ce livre m'a été remis gratuitement
par le Parti socialiste on l'a mis
gratuitement parce qu'il é un petit peu
abîmé et surtoute on n pas voulu me le
faire payer il est indiqué page 243 dans
les entreprises de moins de 10 salariés
où il y a vous le savez le problème des
seuils qui se posent et où la campagne
fait a fait apparître combien ce
problème des seuils est important vous
dites les dispositions seront prises
pour que les travailleurs puissent jouer
également des mêmes droits et être
associé de la même façon aux décisions
les concernants donc au lieu de relever
ou de modifier ces seuils vous les
abaissez vous les faites disparaître de
façon à avoir les mêmes dispositions
contraignantes sur la totalité des
entreprises alors je vous indique qu'à
partir du moment où il y aura dans l'air
la nationalisation de tout le système
bancaire les petites entreprises
n'oseront plus investir lorsqu'il y aura
les projets fiscaux dont nous allons
parler tout à l'heure et notamment les
projets fiscaux sur les successions pour
les petites entreprises elles nuront
plus investir et bien entendu personne
n'embauchera je ne vois pas quelle
entreprise prendra au cours de l'été
1980 la décision d'embaucher et donc
vous verrez arrivver la vague des jeunes
sur le marché du travail sans aucune
structure d'accueil pour leur offrir des
emplois nouveaux c'est la vérité et donc
il faut savoir il faut savoir qu'il n'y
aura pas une diminution du chômage qui
aura une augmentation du chômage
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas extraordinaire
parce que nous ne sommes pas le pays qui
a le pourcentage le plus élevé en Europe
hélas il y a des pays comme par exemple
la Belgique qui ont 10 % de chômeurs à
l'heure actuelle et qui ont eu les
socialistes dans leur gouvernement
jusqu'à la période récente les mesures
que vous proposez conduiront à ce
résultat alors deux questions monsieur
vitérant première question quelle est la
limite du déf nous av un problème nous
avons un problème de temps de parole
excusez-moi nous sommes vous êtes à
égalité mais euh vous nous approchons la
fin du débat sur l'économie pour passer
si vous voulez après à la politique
étrangère donc on vous donne si vous
voulez à Cha chacun de minutes de plus
ça vous fait excusez-moi de tenir ces
compte d'A quel est je crois oui
normalement nous devrions à chacun vous
devriez au bout de 30 minutes avoir
conclu le débat économique nous conevons
qu'il est fort important nous pouvons
donc le prolonger de deux ou 3 minutes
qui seront consommés sur la suite du
débat excusez-nous de faire ces comp TR
questions simples monsieur mit ça me
prendre une minute première question
quel est le montant du déficit
budgétaire que vous jugez acceptable
puisque vous prévoyez une grande
augmentation des dépenses deuxièmement
est-ce que vous maintiendrez le franc
dans le système monétaire européen et
comment le ferez-vous à partir du moment
où le déficit budgétaire créera l'alarme
dans le système monétaire et enfin les
35 he avec quel salaire est-ce que c'est
le salaire de 40 he est-ce que c'est le
salaire de 35 he et je répondrai à vos
questionssur il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire à la fois puisquil me faut
contredire mon interlocuteur et lui
signaler que sur le plan du chômage la
France c'est en 10e rang en triste 10e
rang toujours sur les 15 plus grands
pays industriels pas une réussite je
veux également lui dire que il est
vraiment très difficile de discuter
quand on représente deux politiques
différentes car monsieur jardestin c'est
assez normal d'ailleurs il me place à
l'intérieur de sa politique il raisonne
comme si je devais exercer ma politique
dans le cadre de la sienne bien entendu
j'échouerai comme il a
échoué le point de départ de ma
politique économique elle est
d'une sorte de volonté que vous n'avez
pas eu d'aller vers la croissance non
pas n'importe quelle croissance on va
pas passer comme ça de 0 à à 5
malheureusement il faud bien y arer
chaque point de croissance peut créer
environ disponibilité de 30 milliards 3
points son des 90 une centaine de
milliards permettent déjà à l'état de
disposer de 42 milliards environ puisque
tel est la masse du prélèvement l'état
charges sociales et fiscales la
collectivité peut disposer d'une somme
importante mais c'est pas tellement une
question de chiffre ou une question de
disposition générale ou bien on adopte
une politique dynamique de croissance on
essaie de reconquérir le marché
intérieur on donne les moyens aussi aux
entreprises qui n'ont pas investi car le
profit n'a pas contribuer à
l'investissement pas du tout euh c'est
même une des choses stupéfiantes quand
des erreurs d'analyse du plan juscar bar
au fond les entreprises elles
n'investissent pas leur profit elles
cherchent des marchés il faut leur
procurer des marchés et de ce point de
vue rien ne sera négligé vous pvez poser
trois questions estce que le temps passe
quel est le montant du déficit
budgétaire permettez nous avons une
marge c'est une des rares réussites de
votre
gestion mais vous voyez je les concède
très aisément une autre c'est l'une des
RAC c'est que vous allez faciliter ma
tâche parce que le déficit budgétaire
par rapport au pays voisins par les plus
importants me laisse une marge
suffisante pour continuer de pouvoir
animer l'économie de mon pays 2èmement
le franc restera-t-il dans le système
ben je pense que oui j'espère que ça
marchera bien je ferai tout pour cela si
vous tirez naturellement la conclusion
de votre de votre postulat que il y a un
déficit insupportable naturellement on
ne peut plus rester dans le système mais
comme le déficit sera supportable on
restera dans le système enfin est-ce que
les salaires seront ce euh seront
augmentés ou seront diminués avec le
système des 35h la négociation commence
j'espère qu'elle aboutira dans des dans
des conditions heureuses il n'est pas
question de diminuer les salaires les 35
heur sont faits pour les hommes les
machines tourneront davantage il faut
qu'elles travaillent davantage elles ne
vont pas au bout de leur capacité il
faudra donc de nouvelles équipes la
production et la productivité s'en
tiendront mieux et l'investissement
reprendra je voudrais enfin terminer par
trois trois observations et j'en aurais
fini avec cette partie premièrement mon
programme monsieur vicardesttin il ne
coûtera jamais aussi cher aux Français
que ce que vous leur avez coûté par le
chômage 135 milliards cette année
deuxièmement mon programme ne coûtera
jamais aussi cher que l'emprunt giscar
1973 à 7 % 6 milliards et demi qui
coûtera en 1988
97 milliards on n pas connu dans l ir
financière de la France un emprunt aussi
hasardeux à dexquiler sur le lingo d'or
c'est une faute inimaginable de la part
de quelqu'un qui s'estimait compétent
dans le domaine des finances
troisièmement mon programme ne coûtera
jamais aussi cher que le vol de
l'épargne populaire réalisé par
l'inflation au cours des 7 ans de votre
présidence monsieur je crois que vous
répondez quelqu mot d'abord la volonté
monsieur Vérant il y avait un problème
important dans cette période c'était
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
j'ai posé la question tout à l'heure
tout ce que vous proposez c'est
d'arrêter notre programme national là où
je l'ai conduit donc la volonté aura été
la mienne l'arrêt sera le vôtre et je
vous indique nous pouvons
malheureusement pas en discuter ce
serait important pour les Français de
savoir que avec notre programme
électronucléaire si nous le complétons
vous voulez l'interrompre nous
assurerons notre indépendance
énergétique absolue pendant 5 ans je
veut dire si nous étions coupés de toute
sources d'approvisionnement extérieur
j'ai fait prendre des disposition t que
les Français garderont leur électricité
indépendante pendant 5 ans avec le
pétrole et le garde pendant 3 mois voilà
la volonté nous retrouverons le problème
énergétique au début des questions
internationales si vous voulez alors
déficit vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question vous avez simplement constaté
que nous avions bien géré les finances
publiques françaises et que vous aviez
creusé le déficit je vous en donne acte
j'en a T sûr pu ensuite vous avez dit le
système monétaire européen il serait pas
mal d'y rester ça ne se passe pas comme
ça monsieur mitan actuellement du seul
fait de nos incertitudes politiques nous
sommes au plancher et donc il faut agir
nous agissons à l'heure actuelle nous
sommes passés comme vous le savez pour
le de Mar p dire les chiffres je connais
bien la chute du franc par rapport aux
marqu entre 1974 et aujourd'hui le
chiffre de la journée de la soirée ça
c'est ça s'est aggravé d'abord je n'aime
pas beaucoup hein je vais vous dire les
chiffres mais je n'aime pas beaucoup
cette méthode je ne suis pas votre élève
vous n'êtes pas le président de la
République ici vous êtes simplement mon
contradicteur et et j'entends bien non
pas de cette façon-là je n'accepte pas
cette façon cette fa le fa demander non
non non non pas de cette façon-là ce que
je veux simplement vous dire c'est que
lorsque l'on passe de un 1 franc 87 à 2
francs 35 environ en l'espace de 7 ans
cela n'est pas une réussite pour le
franc pas d'avantage par rapport au
dollar que par rapport au marqu alors je
suis même presque étonné que vous me
lanciez dans cette discussion qui tout
d'un coup se greffe d'une façon un peu
inattendue dans notre conversation alors
qu'elle est plutôt la preuve que le
franc dont on se flatte beaucoup dans
les propos officieles n'a pas pas aussi
bien réussi qu'on le pense si le franc
est resté au contraire une des monnaaies
du monde qui est resté la plus stable au
cours des dernières années et
j'indiquais seulement que dans le
système monétaire européen nous avons
perdu un peu de terrain au cours des
dernières semaines du fait de la du fait
de notre débat politique et que donc si
l'on veut rester dans le système
monétaire européen on ne peut pas dire
on souhaite y rester il faut dire on
agira pour y rester on agira comment on
peut agir soit par les taux d'intérêt
soit par des dispositions concernant les
changes il faut avoir un dispositif à
cet égal à C coût du chômage il ne faut
pas dire au français et au français
parce qu'on ne peut pas leur faire
croire des choses pareilles qu'il est
dans le pouvoir de qui que ce soit et ni
de vous dans votre système de faire
disparaître en quelques mois l'état la
difficulté de l'emploi en France à
l'heure actuelle lorsque vous débattiez
avec Monsieur ronbard il y a quelques
années vous aviez une discussion et vous
vous aviez dit il faut faudra 5 ans pour
faire disparaître le problème de
l'emploi en France vous aviez dit ça en
1977 nous sommes en 1982 donc de toute
façon vous l'auriez même pas encore fait
disparaître donc on ne peut pas dire que
le coûte c'est un coût que nous avons
créé ou imposé en quelque sorte à
l'économie française et on ne peut pas
considérer que vous disposerez des
ressources correspondant à la réduction
rapide des charges du chômage parce que
les charges du chômage vous me les
reproché mais c'est une aide apportée
aux chômeurs et si nous n'avions pas eu
un dispositif de soutien des revenus des
chômeurs nous aurions eu la dépression
des années 30 si nous avons au contraire
évité cette dépression je vous rappelle
que dans toute cette période nous
n'avons jamais eu de croissance négative
en France jamais et que nous avons eu
une seule année avec une croissance
nulle 75 c'est parce que nous avons
maintenu le revenu des chômeurs au
travers d'un système qui est d'ailleurs
un système de politique contractuelle
géré avec les syndicats et enfin quant à
l'emprunt 73 on pas entrer dans une
discussion de ce type je vous indique
simplement que l'État a gagné autant
qu'il a perdu dans cette affaire car
comme l'État avait acheté par mes soins
des quantité importantes d'or dans toute
la période précédente comme nous avions
échangé nos réserves en dollars contre
des réserves en Nord l'État a gagné tout
autant qu'il verse au titre de l'emprunt
il se trouve seulement que les
souscripteurs à cet emprunt se trouvent
placés dans la même situation que celle
de l'État français en ce qui concerne la
gestion de ces réserves d'or et enfin
les derniers emprunts qui ont été lancé
quelqu été les circonstances actuelles
ont été lancé à des taux d'intérêt
positifs le dernier était vous le savez
aux alentours de 14 % pourquoi c'était
précisément pour faire en sorte que
l'épargne qui apporté son concours à
l'état ne se voit pas privé de
rémunération et donc à cet égard l'État
a tenu compte des obligations qu'il a
vis-à-vis de l'épargne populaire je
crois que les les Français qui nous
regardent ne comprendraient pas que nous
n'évoquions pas le problème de la
fiscalité car tout le monde paye des
impôts et nous pouvons peut-être
consacré de ou 2 minutes supplémentaires
au problèmes fiscaux vous avez tous les
deux curieusement pris des engagements
dans ce domaine pendant cette campagne
électoral et je dirais les engagements
de même nature comme si un vent venu
d'Amérique vous avez converti l'un et
l'autre à la nécessité de rassurer les
Français si vous vouliez solliciter leur
suffrage dans ce domaine monsieur
miteran a dit le la pression fiscale
c'est-à-dire le volume des impôts et des
cotisations sociales par rapport au
revenus des Français ne sera pas alourdi
par rapport à ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
et Monsieur Valéri visiscardestin a
déclaré si je l'ai bien entendu
récemment qu'il s'engagea lui à faire
mieux encore à la ramener de 42 %
c'estàdire que pour 100 fr de revenu on
pie 42 francs d'impôt et de cotisation
sociale à 40 % c'est que pour 100 francs
de revenu on ne perait plus que 40
francs d'impôt et de cotisation
sociale personnellement je suis toujours
éberlué de ce type de promesse mais
probablement que vous avez l'un et
l'autre des raisons fortes pour
démontrer que vous pouvez les tenir
est-ce que je peux ajouter deux
questions mais qui sont dans ce domaine
monsieur fr Mitterant pour vous le le
point central est un impôt sur le
capital mais faire payer les riches
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et à partir
de quand est-on riche monsieur GIS
cardestin vous avez créé deux impôts
pendant votre septena l'impôts sur les
plus-valu et la taxe professionnelle al
l'impôt sur les plus-valu tronqué par le
Parlement peut-être mais n'a pas été
appliqué autant que vous l'auriez
souhaité et la taxe professionnelle a
été en quelque sorte la vedette de cette
campagne puisque Jacques Chirac en a
réclamé la suppression et vous-même
maintenant vous en réclamer la réforme
alors peut-on faire des réformes
fiscales en France quand on est Valé
gardestin je crois que le temps de
parole c'est à Monsieur c'est à moi de
parler le premier allez-y choisissez
vous vous avez de l'avance alors nos
programmes fiscaux sont totalement
différents totalement différent et c'est
normal puisque vous avez une conception
différente de la nôtre en ce qui
concerne l'impôt sur le revenu vous
envisagez de l'alourdir de l'alléger
dans les basses tranches de l'alourdir
dans les tranches moyennes et
supérieures moi je suis partisan de
l'allègement de l'ensemble de notre
système d'impôt sur le revenu pour deux
raisons la première c'est que je crois
qu'il faut élargir les tranches du barem
comme nous l'avons fait fait cette année
et ensuite j'ai observé c'est un des
points sur lesquels nous n'avons pas agi
comme nous le devions que les classes
moyennes catégorie des employés des
cadres avaent une surcharge fiscale au
titre de l'impôt sur le revenu
importante au cours des dernières années
je suis donc favorable à l'élargissement
progressif des tranches moyennes ce qui
est difficile et coûteux et qui donc
doit se faire sur quelques années je
suis contre l'augmentation les tranches
moyennes monsieur juscard desestin ce
sont des gens qui ont un revenu de quel
ordre de grandeur qui on un revenu
compris entre le foyer puis que nous
ronnons par foyer fiscal compris entre
8000 francs et 15000 francs VO s'il y a
deux salaires ou un gros salaire ou deux
salaires moyens de salaires moyens
naturellement on élargit également les
AR les tranches proportionnellement mais
il y a là incontestablement un poids
trop lourd de l'IMP deuxièmement je suis
contre la disposition proposée au cours
du débat de l'automne dernier par le
Parti socialiste et qui j'ai là
l'amendement numéro 40 du 16 octobre
1980 majorant les droits de succession à
partir de 500000 francs en ligne directe
500000 francs vous voyez ce que ça veut
dire pour les exploitations agricoles
pour les propriétaires de leurs logement
pour les propriétaires de leur fond de
commerce ou de leur petite entreprise
les droits sont actuellement de 20 %
dans cet amendement qui a été déposé je
l'ai là il passerait à 45 %. le problème
à l'heure actuelle au contraire c'est de
préserver le capital de ces petits
producteurs si on leur prend la moitié
lorsque ça passe du Père au fils ou du
mari à la femme il est impossible qu'il
continuent leur activité je suis donc
contre cette formule il y a dans votre
projet que j'ai sous les yeux la
suppression du cootient familial qui
sera d'abord plafonné puis supprimé je
suis contre la suppression du cootient
familial c'est une des mesures
d'encouragement à la famille qui a été
la plus efficace en France en ce qui
concerne les plus-values j'ai indiqué
que j'étais favorable à un système de
type forfaitaire on a voulu faire une
législation très compliquée je vous
rappelle que le Président de la
République ne participe pas aux
délibérations parlementaires ce système
était sans doute trop perfectionné et
trop compliqué et finalement a fait
apparaître un certain nombre de défauts
donc je suis favorable au retour à un
système de taxation forfaitaire suivant
les types de plus-value et la taxe
professionnelle et enfin la taxe
professionnel je vous rappelle que je
neavais pas proposé comme ministre des
Finances qu'elle a été assez
profondément transformée au cours du
débat parlementaire de 1975 auquel je ne
participais pas et que depuis on s'est
efforcé de la réformer et il y a une
commission parlementaire qui est au
travail qui a d'ailleurs reçu mandat de
l'assemblée de présenter des
propositions pour le prochain budget je
souhaite que ces propositions puissent
venir en discussion et qu'on puisse
réformer ainsi la taxe professionnelle
au fond monsieur jbestin pour un
monarque républicain vous avez fort peu
de pouvoir puisque quand vous êtes
président l'assemblée fait des choses
qui vous déplaisent et votre Ministre
des Finances aussi non mais en matière
de fiscalité c'est un fait que le
Président de la République n'intervient
pas dans le débat fiscal parlementaire
tout le monde le sait il peut donner des
indications marquer des préf
partipe pas à la discussion V des
projets monsieur vous répondez sur
l'info sur le capital je vais répondre
encore une fois de façon trop rapide
maisous pas
tempous av déjàp simplement il faudra
que ceux qui nous écoute remplisse mon
raisonnement qui va être très sec je
dirais simplement que le prélèvement
fiscal les impôt et soci sécurité
sociale est passé de 36% à 2 % pendant
ce SEP 36 à 42 % c'est-à-dire que si
tout cela a été augmenté c'est dans le
cadre de la gestion de Monsieur lcard
Tout ça pour être clair simplement parce
qu'près tout je comprends qu'il étude
des problèmes deuxièmement si je veux en
rester à 42 % malgré les charges que je
prévois c'est parce que j'entends
engager une autre politique notamment
une politique de croissance et en même
temps une nouvelle répartition et
j'arrive à votre question à l'intérieur
de ces 42 % bien entendu 42 % de 3000
milliards sur le ce n'est pas la même
chose que 42 % sur 3500 milliards de
produits intérieur brut bon d'autre part
pour poser la question sur l'Impôt sur
les grandes fortunes
oui à partir de 3 millions de francs 300
millions de centimes compte non tenu
évidemment de l'instrument de travail
c'estàdire que l'instrument de travail
la terre pour l'agriculteur euh dans
l'entreprise ou dans le commerce
l'instrument du travail ne compte pas ne
sont pas décomptés dans ces sommes de 3
millions de francs ou de 300 millions de
centimes et nous considérons que c'est
indispensable pour parvenir à
l'élargissement du barê de l'impôt sur
le revenu dont a parlé monsieur
giscardestin parce que je me demande où
il compense et comment il compense la
perte de recettes pour l'État moi je
pense qu'on ne peut la compenser que si
les très haut revenus sont frappés
c'estàdire les grandes fortunes à partir
de là on pourra permettre précisément
que les cadres dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure soient mises à l'abri des
charges trop lourdes qui pèsent sur eux
je voudrais maintenant également en deux
mots préciser monsieur viscardestin que
il n'est pas exact car j'ai déposé un
programme pendant cette campagne vous
auriez pu en prendre connaissance je
reconnais que vous avez beaucoup de
choses à faire vous aussi mais je tiens
absolument à dire que je tiens au
contraire à supprimer les droits de
succession en ligne directe ou entrépou
au bénéfice de charge plus lourd pour
les successions pour des collatéraux ou
des personnes éloignées deuxièmement que
je ne demande pas la suppression du
coocient familial c'est une erreur je
demande son plafonnement troisièmement
je ne demande pas je suis candidat à la
présidence de la République mon
programme a été imprimé pour pourrez en
prendre connaissance troisièmement que
la taxe professionnelle monsieur Chirac
et Monsieur lisardesttin s'en disputeent
la paternité ils ont fait un mauvais
impôt ils en sont responsables je n'y pu
rien bien nous passons peut-être si vous
voulez bien à la politique étrangère
monsieur juscard destin vous avez un un
léger retard sur votre alors je voulais
commencer en parlant de l'Europe
peut-être faut-il Michel faire
l'articulation avec la politique
énergétique puisque c'est autant de la
politique économique que de la politique
internationale or c'est un point tout à
fait capital monsieur jiscardestin
souhaitait interroger monsieur miteran
qui je pense souhaite s'expliquer sur ce
terrain monsieur jiscardestin j'ai
demandé à Monsieur mitan pourquoi
veut-il interrompre le programme
électroluclaire français exactement là
où je l'ai conduit alors que je
considère que la poursuite de ce
programme électronucléaire est
indispensable pour assurer
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
et pour nous libérer de la
contrainte humiliante et inquiétante des
producteurs de pétrole sur la France au
point de vue de nos approvisionnements
et de nos prix mais je veux autant que
vous assurer l'indépendance énergétique
de la France c'est une démarche
nationale il n a pas pas un Français qui
conscient et responsable qui ne le
veuille c'est évident simplement je ne
prends pas le même itinéraire que vous
vous misez sur ce que l'on appelle le
tout nucléaire vous mettez tous les œufs
dans le même panier pas moi je pense
qu'il est possible de diversifier
d'avantage les ressources énergétiques
je pense qu'il est possible de réveiller
plus que vous ne le faites le charbon
notamment avec les techniques modernes
de la carbochimique je pense que l'on
peut plus que vous ne le faites contre
bu au développement des énergies
renouvelables non polluantes je pense
que l'on peut faire plus que vous ne le
faites des économies d'énergie dont la
commission énergie du 8e plan disait que
c'était l'axe principal de
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
ce qui peut me permettre je le pense
très sérieusement d'aboutir absolument
au même chiffre c'est-à-dire au mêmes
millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole
sans précipiter notre marche en avant
vers le tout nucléire je demande donc à
parachever les centrales nucléaires en
construction et avant d'entreprendre un
plan je veux savoir exactement de quoi
il le retourne il est quand même normal
que je fasse votre bilan surtout lorsque
je sais vous le savez sans doute comme
moi que les technologies du nucléaire
sont très changeantes vous savez très
bien queon commence à débattre
simplement à distance d'une génération
du problème de la fusion des atomes
d'hydrogène et que l'on ne s'en tiendra
plus d'ici peu de temps au problème de
la fission de l'uranium l'otope 235
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes dans une
charnière au cours de laquelle il
convient de ne pas exposer la France à
une extension et définie d'un type de
technologie nucléaire qui peut-être
dommageable étant bien entendu que comme
il faut assurer le présent et
l'immédiate à venir faire tourner nos
usines assurer le chauffage et le reste
j'entends mener hardiment de font les
quatre types d'énergie nucléaire
économie d'énergie renouvelaable et
anciennes énergies qui doivent me
permettre de diversifier d'une façon
plus heureuse ce que vous avez-vous
simplifié référendum sur le nucléaire ou
pas monsieur mitéron pardon référendum
sur le nucléaires ou pas c'est une
proposition en effet que j'ai faite
seulement elle Ste à une grande
difficulté c'est la réforme de la
Constitution comme tous ces référendum à
la Suisse dont vous avez parlé sur
lequel vous avez bien voulu vous ranger
à mon avis il est certain que ce type de
référendum serait très heureux mais
comme la la Constitution s'y oppose
avant qu'on soit parvenu à modifier la
réforme de la Constitution vous savez
nous aurons tellement de choses à faire
après le 25 mai que je ne veux pas me
consacrer les travaux de juristes je
veux entrer dans l'action m'attaquer au
chômage et au reste une dernière
question sur le problème de ma part oui
monsieurardestin mais avant sur le point
précis du nucléaire et des décisions
juridiques est-ce que vous donneriez à
une commune le droit de vetto contre
l'installation d'une centrale nucléaire
sur son territoire le droit de
vetonant jusqu
la consultation existe déjà Paso lui
donner je note sur le programme
nucléaire monsur que chaque fois que
vous avez une décision à prendre la
décision vous proposez c'est simplement
de vous contenter d'arrêter ce qu'on
décid les autres vous l'avz déjà proposé
pas nouveau vous l'z proposé en 1977
proposé en 1977 vous le reconnaissez un
moratoire sur le nucléaire t les
Français s'en souviennent et donc le
programme qui aura été fait de 1977 à
1981 aura été fait sans vous vous l'avez
pas soutenu ou facilité alors maintenant
vous dites j'empoche votre nucléaire si
je comprends bien et je ne décide de
rien moi-même et vous présentez si c'est
ce que vous dites vous dites je
continuerai ce que vous avez décidé je
ne décide rien et simplement vous
appuyez sur des évaluations sur ce qu'on
pourrait faire d'autres alors vous avez
parlé de la fusion des atomes
d'hydrogène vous savez très bien que C
n'est pas avant l'an 2020 que cela peut
devenir industriel nous sommes en 1981
n'allons pas attendre l'an 2020 pour
pour assurer notre indépendance
énergétique moi j'ai fixé un objectif
pour 90 et cet objectif c'est que nous
ayons aux alentours de la moitié de
notre indépendance énergétique toutes
les économies d'énergie nous les faisons
toutes les recherches nouvelles sur la
biomasse le carburant l'énergie solaire
nous les faisons j'ai créé le
commissariat à l'énergie solaire
l'utilisation du charbon monsieur girud
qui est compétent en la matière a
élaborer un plan d'utilisation
d'inventaire maxima de nos ressources
Charbonnières je l'ai redit l'autre jour
dans le Pas de calis donc nous savons
très bien ce que nous pouvons faire à
partir de nos ressources non nucléaires
si nous ne faisons rien de plus dans le
domaine nucléaire nous n'atteindrons pas
notre objectif de moitié l'indépendance
énergétique dans les années 90 alors au
fond pendant votre SEPA vous verrez
arriver les centrales que j'ai décidé et
puis ensuite il y aura un trou dans
l'approvisionnement de la France parce
qu'on aura pas pris les décisions
suivantes la difficulté ça n'est pas
d'achever les travaux la difficulté
c'est de décider la construction de
centrales nouvelles et je vous disais
tout à l'heure je dis aux
téléspectateurs parce qu'il faut qu'il
voit l' je quand on est président de la
République on ne peut pas dire je verra
plus tard et ceera on prend des
décisions j'ai pris la décision avec le
gouvernement bien entendu
d'approvisionner la France en uranium de
telle manière que quoi qu'il arrive dans
le monde à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
avons notre production d'électricité
nucléaire assurée pour les 5 ans
suivantes il peut y avoir une guerre il
peut y avoir une crise au Proche Orient
tout ce qu'on nous avons pendant 5 ans
l'électricité assurée pour les Français
l'électricité ça veut dire l'électricité
domestique mais aussi la artisanat
l'agriculture et de plus en plus
l'industrie si nous continuons notre
programme électronucléaire nous aurons
l'électricité nationale la moins chère
d'europee et nous aurons un avantage de
l'ordre de 30 à 50 % suivant les types
de courant vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne
fédérale ça vaut la peine si on veut
s'occuper du développement de l'emploi
et l'activité économique en France
d'avoir le courant électrique le moins
cher d'Europe et donc je considère que
c'est un intérêt national que de
poursuivre ce programme et d'ailleurs je
note que si on l'arrête du point de vue
de l'emploi du point de vue du
développement no activités industrielle
c'est une décision négative ce n'est pas
une décision
positiveonsant si vous voulez bien un
problème de l'Europe au fond je dire
simplement si vous permettez madame je
je veux dire que je je n'arrête
absolument pas de la façon que vient de
dire monsieur valer viscardestin
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
j'ai là moi mon projet et mon projet
aboutit en
1990 à ce que
230 millions de tonnes équivalents en
pétrole puisse être mise à notre
disposition de telle sorte que notre
indépendance sera en chemin et la
différence avec le projet de Monsieur J
cardestin est extrêmement mince
j'entends simplement diversifier je ne
récuse pas le nucléaire j'entends le
maîtriser c'est tout ce que je veux dire
et je voudrais simplement signaler que
les économies d'énergie peuvent
représenter un moyen formidable qui n'a
pas été suffisamment utilisé par le
pendant le SEPA de Monsieur giscardestin
et qui doit me permettre d'aboutir
autant que Monsieur G destin à
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
pour favoriser les économies d'énergie
monsieur midéran êtes-vous favorable à
la répercussion intégrale de la hausse
du dollar sur le prix de
l'essence la répercussion du dollar sur
le prix de l'essence a naturellement une
incidence dans notre conversation mais
les économies d'énergie que j'entends
aujourd'hui mener à bien elles le seront
par des incitations à l'intérieur même
de l'économie française dans le cadre de
notre politique sans avoir à faire avec
les cours internationaux ce sont des
techniques tout à fait connues qui sont
tout à fait à la mesure de multiples
petites et moyennes entreprises que de
parvenir sur le plan du logement sur le
plan du transport et alors sur le plan
industriel par le développement des
composants électroniques à une très
puissante économie d'énergie qui répond
à la question posée c'est tout ce que
veux dire parce que le temps passe et
nous avons encore beaucoup de choses à
dire al vous avez été largement l'un et
l'autre favorable à l'élection de
l'assemblée européenne au suffrage
universel aujourd'hui sans doute les
résultats n'ont pas atteint vos
espérances à tous les deux alors
concrètement êtes-vous tous les deux
pour l'entrée du Portugal et de
l'Espagne dans le marché commun
êtes-vous tous les deux pour le maintien
de l'Angleterre dans le marché commun
monsieur juscard destin très
simplement je suis pour le maintien de
l'Angleterre dans le marché commun dans
selon les dispositions exist ente du
traité de Rome je me suis batttu depuis
un an pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
modification de ces dispositions ni en
ce qui concerne la pêche ni en ce qui
concerne l'agriculture je n'accepterai
pas des modifications de ces
dispositions si elle devait être demandé
comme la condition du maintien de la
Grande-Bretagne dans le marché commun en
ce qui concerne l'Espagne et le Portugal
j'ai indiqué qu'il fallait une
négociation très attentive car leur
situation économique la situation de
certaines de leur production est très
différente de la nôtre et notamment les
productions agricoles médit terranéenne
donc il y a une négociation en cours
cette négociation doit être conduite
avec toute la minutie désirable et elle
doit comporter en particulier une longue
période de transition à l'heure actuelle
les Espagnols paraissent demander
eux-même une durée de 10 ans et en même
temps des garanties concernant
l'organisation des marchés des
productions Méditerranées est-ce que
vous n'espériez pas au début que ça
irait plus vite et qu'il n'y aurait pas
besoin de faire de décréter une pause
non pas du tout j'ai toujours distingué
deux choses qui était la position
politique de la France je disais d'un
point de vue politique la France qui est
la voisine et l'amie des pays latins ne
va pas prendre une position négative
alors que tous les autres pays d'Europe
sont favorables mais j'ai indiqué dès le
départ je vous renvoie un discours que
j'ai prononcé à Carpentra cette égard
j'ai indiqué qu'il fallait une
négociation très attentive une longue
période de transition et des garanties
pour nos productions méditerranéennes je
n'ai pas changé la vi monsieur Giscard
desestin vous dites le maintien de la
Grande-Bretagne dans le marché commun
dépend de telle ou telle condition mais
avez-vous le moindre moyen de faire
sortir la Grande-Bretagne du marché
commun si les Anglais ne veulent pas en
sortir là il faudrait malheureusement
plus de temps je dis simplement vous
avez mal interprété ma pensée j'ai dit
que j'étais favorable à ce que la
Grande-Bretagne reste dans le marché
commun à condition bien entendu qu'elle
accepte le les règles qui régissent le
marché commun c'est-à-dire les règles du
traité de Rome or la Grande-Bretagne ne
peut pas modifier les règles du traité
de Rome si donc elle estimait que ces
règles ne lui convenaient pas c'est elle
qui devrait en tirer des conséquences et
ça n'est pas nous je dis simplement que
nous ne modifierons pas les règles du
traité de Rome pour faciliter ou
maintenir l'adhésion de tel ou tel pays
particulier est pas que la politique
agricole commune européenne où se décide
le sort des paysans français aujourd'hui
car tout cela ne dépend plus seulement
de Paris ne soit bloqué par le système
tel qu'il existe alors premièrement nous
avons obtenu une décision sur les prix
que nous avons obtenu au pris d'un débat
difficile où je me suis engagé
personnellement et j'indique à notre
agriculture que Monsieur mitérant
c'était peut-être pour vous faire
plaisir monsieur jusardesttin et parce
qu'on CIT pour tenir compte de
l'importance que nous attachions à la
situation de l'agriculture française et
européenne faire plaisir ça n'a pas de
sens et j'indique aux agriculteurs
français que l'effort pour l'année 1980
c'est de modérer les coûts de production
de façon à ce que les coûts de
production soi inférieurs évolution soit
inférieur à ce qui a été décidé pour les
prix c'est pour les prix on a obtenu
12,2 % et vous savez que le rythme
actuel de hausse des prix en France a
diminué d'environ un point depuis le
début de l'année il est encore à l'heure
actuelle trop fort il est de l'ordre de
12,5 % environ si nous poursuivons notre
effort nous serons à la fin de l'année
nous devons être normalement d'après
évaluations à un rythme qui sera
inférieur à l'augmentation des pris
agricoles et les dispositions seront
prises pour que l'augmentation des coûts
de production en agriculture ne soit pas
supérieure à la Haus des prix que nous
avons obtenu à Bruxelles quant au reste
la discussion sur le marché commun
agricole je vous répète il y a des
règles et ce sont ceux qui demandent des
modifications de ces règles qui sont en
position de faiblesse alors qu'on peut
toujours faire croire aux Français que
ce sont ceux qui comme nous souhaitons
simplement le maintien des règles qui
sont en péril nous nous battrons pour le
maintien des règles existantes du Marché
Commun agricole monsieur mitéron sur
l'Europe et bien je
suis
favorable au maintien des 10 pays qui se
trouvent actuellement dans l'Europe du
Marché Commun même
si certains de ces pays ne se comportent
pas comme je le
souhaiterais je voudrais simplement que
notre diplomatie surtout face à la
Grande-Bretagne soit plus vigilante elle
ne l'a pas été dans l'affaire des
moutons elle ne l'a pas été dans
l'affaire des pêcheurs elle ne l'a été
qu'insuffisamment dans l'affaire des
prises agricoles deuxièmement pour
l'Espagne et le Portugal j'ai fait
valoir avant 1979 c'està-dire les
élections européennes ce que je pensais
de ce problème j'ai posé divers
préalable économique agricole industriel
caractère régional caractère de la pêche
en Méditerranée à l'entrée de l'Espagne
notamment à l'époque quelqu'un m'a
contredit avec une certaine véhéence
c'était monsieur jcardestin qui estimait
que c'était absurd et avoir le regard
tourné vers le passé que de refuser
l'entrée
immédiateespagne et du Portugal dans le
marché commun je suis heureux de voir
que le bon sens l'a emporté et que
finalement le président de la République
che cardesttin ces fonctions exprimé et
rejoint mon point de vue dans cette
affaire l'Europe c'est une affaire de
volonté c'est aussi une affaire
d'intérêt sans doute encore faut-il
vouloir faire de l'Europe une force
politique et économique social culturel
qui soit en mesure de restituer à chacun
des pays qui la compos le rang que la
France tient encore mais dont elle a
bien besoin pour face aux
superpuissances disposé d'alliés sûrs
qui représenteront une force commune
dans le monde c'est vrai déjà du plan
commercial cela devrait être vrai dans
toututre domaines sans quoi l'Europe se
dissociera inévitablement monsieur
mitteran pour gérer l'Europe il faut de
l'argent dans la caisse or il semble que
le budget de la communauté atteigne la
limite des prélèvements autorisé
aujourd'hui sur les ressources de la
communauté êtes-vous favorable à
l'accroissement des ressources propres
de la communauté c'est-à-dire à lever un
impôt supplémentaire qui lui soit
destiné c'est une très grande difficulté
si est mal géré moi je n'y suis pour
rien ce qui est vrai c'est que il faut
que la communauté dans la mesure par
rapport aux parlements nationaux il ne
faut pas qu'elle déborde par rapport au
gouvernement nationaux par rapport au
pays qui la compos il faut pas qu'elle
déborde et pourtant je lui reconnais un
grand rôle notamment dans le domaine des
relations entre l'Europe et le tirmonde
quand on pense que la communauté exporte
40 % de ces marchandises vers le
tirmonde je pense que là on manque une
très grande occasion de développer nos
industrie de rallumer notre croissance
par une politique audacieuse
intelligente et généreuse à l'égard du
timonde
vous me direz Simp ce que vous nous
reprochez en matière de pêche concernant
l'action diplomatique de la France et
vous m'expliquerez pourquoi Monsieur
mitan le groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
parlementaire européenne a voté pour une
augmentation des prix agricoles de 7 %
alors que nous avons ob tenu 12,2 % lors
de la discussion de Bruxelles on reprend
cette
discussion sur ce point précisre chose
sur la pêche vous avez échoué par je
crois manque de ténacité dans l'affaire
de Mastricht je sais bien que vous
monter un peu sur le délai de 82 c'està
dire arriver à enferber la
Grande-Bretagne dans un délai de
disposition transitoire qui feront
qu'elle sera for close si j'ose dire au
moment o il voudra fermer à nouveau
continuer de fermer les bancs de pêche
pêcheurs venus de chez nous je pense que
là vous avez manqué de fermeté ça vous
arrive assez souvent monsieuron je vous
arrête tout de suite expliquez-vous vous
savez parfaitement pas du tout expliquez
vous Z manqué de fermeté ce sont des
propos désobligeants n'est- pas quand je
vous demande le
une offense vous que j'ai manqua de
fermeté pour défendre les intérêts de la
France et ceci fait partie de la
conversation à mastrich c'était la
Grande-Bretagne qui était demandresse ça
n'était pas nous et donc quandci il y a
eu échec c'est un échec de la
GrandeBretagne la position de la France
dans laffaire de la pêche c'est tout à
fait simple nous demandons qu'on s'en
tienne aux accords existants et le pays
qui demande une modification de ces
accords c'est la Grande-Bretagne tant
qu'il n'y a pas d'accord la position qui
est maintenue et la position qui défend
les intérêts des pêcheurs français et
d'ailleurs à l'heure actuelle aucun de
nos zones de pêche n'est effectivement
troublé donc je n'admet pas qu'on
présente un échec de la Grande-Bretagne
en ce qui concerne les demandes
nouvelles concernant des droits de pêche
comme un échec de la France nous passons
peut-être en attendant nos pêcheurs
savent très bien à quoi s'en tenir et
c'est eux qui con une question vous a
été posée sur le fait que le groupe
socialiste au Parlement européen si j'ai
bien compris ce qui ne concerne pas le
seul parti socialiste français
probablement avait voté une demand
demande de 7 et5 % d'augmentation des pr
agricoles 7 j'ai pris une position qui
m'engage en demandant une augmentation
de 15 % le gouvernement n'a obtenu que
12,5i % c'est mieux que rien ce n'était
pas suffisant c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire là-dessus on on en arrête peut-être
avec la pêche si vous voulez bien non je
crois qu'il faut qu'il faut aborder les
problèmes des relations est ouest vous
avez les questions de défense et les
questions de défense bien entendu euh
les relation vous avez eu directement ou
indirectement une grande controverse à
propos euh du de la rencontre que
monsieur jusardestin a eu à varsevie
avec Monsieur brageneev vous apprécierez
s'il convient que vous riez sur cette
querelle mais il y a une question me
semble-t-il que les Français se posent
dans l'hypothèse où l'Union soviétique
serait amené à intervenir à nouveau dans
un pays extérieur à elle-même ce fut le
cas en Afghanistan ce pourrait être
éventuellement le cas en Europe
orientale ou ailleurs quelles sont les
sanctions que vous souhaiteriez voir
prendre pour répliquer à une telle
intervention et la croyez-vous possible
voire
probable monsieur prier j'ai un peu de
retard sur Monsieur J cardestin vous
allez l'accroître si c'est moi qui
commence oui mais concluez vite répondez
viteou j'ai en effet
condamné le voyage de Monsieur J
cardestin à Varsovie dans les conditions
où ce voyage s'est produit je trouve
tout à fait normal que le Président de
la République rencontre qui il veut si
cela sert les intérêts de la France je
pense que peu de temps après l'invasion
de l'Afghanistan c'était un geste qui
cautionnait un acte contraire au droit
des gens au droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêm et que tout acte de ce genre
est naturellement dommageable pour la
paix et comme une controverse s'est
engagée à ce sujet je voudrais faire
deux remarques pour bien montrer que
telle était l'intention de monsieur
gicardestin se rend à barsovi que de
faire autre chose que ce qu'il a dit
dans une conférence de presse parlant du
peuple afghan qui se bat pour sa liberté
il a dit les
rebelles et le 1er mai de l'année
suivante en
1980 l'ambassadeur de France était le
seul ambassadeur des pays occidentaux à
se trouver au défilé de la Place Rouge
c'est-à-dire que dans cette faire et il
me semble et moi je suis très partisan
naturellement d'un accord avec la Russie
mais dans la fermeté et non pas dans une
certaine forme de soumission au fait
accomplis voilà ce que je veux dire vous
savez jeai pas accepté les propos
désobligeants tenu par Monsieur François
mitteran vis-à-vis du président de la
République française lorsqu'il a
commenté de façon sarcastique la
rencontre de varsevie à la télévision je
ne rappellerai même pas les termes que
vous avez employés vous ne le souhaitez
pas lorsqu'on doit juger un acte il faut
en connaître le déroulement je vous
rappellerai d'abord ce qu' a été la
déclaration elle mérite la lecture du
Parti socialiste après les événements
d'Afghanistan le 2 janvier 1980 après
qu'il y ait déjà eu les déclarations
publiques des pays occidentau le Parti
socialiste a dit ceci à la suite de
l'invasion de l'Afghanistan par les
troupes soviétiques le bureau exécutif
du parti socialiste déclare le Parti
socialiste condamne cette intervention
comme il a condamné les interventions
américaines en Asie du Sud et en
Amérique Latine ou les interventions du
gouvernement français en Afrique voilà
la position qui a été prise sur
l'Afghanistan si je suis allé à Varsovie
j'y suis allé au printemps je ne suis
pas allé dans les semaines qui ont suivi
l'entrée des troupes soviétiques en
Afghanistan c'est parce que j'ai échangé
dans l'intervalle plusieurs messages
avec le président bregenenev et que la
lecture de ces messages que je ne peux
pas rendre publ faisait apparaître que
vous connaîtrez le moment venu si vous
accédez à nos archives bien entendu
faisait apparaître qu'il y avait eu de
grandes hésitations dans la direction
soviétique et un débat et même un doute
sur la décision d'intervenir en
Afghanistan je me suis donc dit il y a
des éléments qui doivent être portés à
la connaissance des plus hautes
autorités soviétiques directement au cas
où des situation similaires viendrai à
se reproduire et ce que je suis allé
dire monsieur bregner c'est que les
évaluations ou les conséquences qui lui
avaient été décrite concernant l'entrée
des forces soviétiques en Afghanistan
était inexacte on lui avait dit sans
doute que c'était une opération qui
durerait quelques semaines qu'il n'y
aurait pas de résistance du peuple
afghan et que donc il n'y aurait pas des
conséquences importantes sur les
relations internationales je suis venu
lui dire c'était le contraire et je lui
indiquis également que comme nous le
disons dans notre communiqué franco
allemand et vous répuier peut-être la
partie française mais le Chanier Schmith
avait signé avec moi ce document le 5
février 1980 que tout nouveau manquement
à la détente entraînerait les
conséquences les plus graves dans les
relations Est-Ouest et c'est ma réponse
à votre question je crois que nous ne
devons pas agir quand on est un homme
d'État uniquement comme un prophète qui
prévoit les événements mais comme
quelqu'un qui façonne les événements et
concernant les relations avec l'Union
soviétique nous devons tenter de les
maintenir dans toute la mesure du
possible dans le chemin du règlement
pacifique des situations à partir d'une
situation de force et alors monsieur
miterant ne me parlez pas de faiblesse
alors que vous n'avez pas voté un
centime de crédit militaire depuis 1958
et que donc toute la force française
s'est faite alors que vous étiez
parlementaire sans un seul vote de votre
part et c'est donc nous qui avons eu la
responsabilité de la puissance et de la
force militaire de la France dans
l'intervalle mais j'avais à dire des
choses importantes à Monsieur brchneev
s'il y avait eu un président des
États-Unis capable de mener à cette
époque un dialogue de haut niveau il e
été utile qu'il le fasse de son côté je
note qu'on a critiqué ma rencontre à
varsevie mais qu'on a pas critiqué le
voyage du chancelier Schmidt à Moscou au
mois de juin je serais curieux de saavir
pourquoi et qu'on n pas critiqué non
plus le voyage de Monsieur gcher à
Moscou qui vient de se produire il y a
quelques
semaines vous connaissez cette
déclaration pardon je vous enpr vous
connaissez cette déclaration de Monsieur
Chirac le 9 mars 1980 nous parlons de ce
problème l'invasion de l'Afghanistan
c'est une honte de s'êtretu dans cette
circonstance et il parlait de vous donc
je ne suis pas le seul à avoir éprouvé
un sentiment de malaise au moment de
votre visite à Varsovie c'est tout ce
que je voulais dire je voulais vous
poser une double question puisque vous
avez abordé par un biais la politique
africaine non revenons à la défense ma
question monsieur président de la
République n'a pas voté un centime de
crédit pour la défense de la France j'ai
vérifié tous les votes non non mais je
nous allonsir je répondre d'un mot à
cette affaire je suis dans l'opposition
et je suis hostile à l'ensemble
dispositions budgétaire qui sont prises
par les gouvernements que je combats et
bien entendu à l'intérieur de ces
dispositions est-ce que monsieurardestin
voudrait dire que les socialistes
seraient de mauvais français qui ne
veulent pas défendre leur pays bon comme
il veut pas dire cela c'était donc une
parole inutile non non c'est pas du tout
une parole inutile monsieur mitteran
parce que vous êtes allé beaucoup plus
loin vous avez voté des textes
législatifs pendant cette période j'ai
là sous les yeux la liste des textes de
lois que vous avez voté donc vous en
avez voté lorsque ils étaient conformes
au vu du Parti socialiste notamment
certains projets de loi qui ont été
présentés du temps de mon septenard mais
lorsqu'il s'est agi de la défense vous
avez au contraire vous n'avez jamais
voté à crédit de défense et vous avez
voté contre toutes les lois de programme
relativ à la défense ces lois de
programme étaient présenté en dehors de
la discussion budgétaire et donc on
pouvait très bien imaginer que soit
votre parti soit votre soit vous-même
conscient du très grand enjeu du
problème de la sécurité de la France et
mett un vote non partisan sur les lois
de programme militaire je note que vous
n'avez voté aucune des trois lois de
programme militaire vous êtes allé plus
loin d'ailleurs car vous avez accompagné
vos votes d'explications et ces
explications étaient contraires à notre
effort de dissuasion à
notamment le 24 janvier 1963 à
l'Assemblée nationale quand nous
engagions ce grand
programme je voudrais donc parler de la
poli tout à fait bien sû mais après
c'est une question qui s'adresse à vous
deux après 7 ans Monsieur gcardestin
n'avez-vous pas l'impression d'avoir en
ce qui concerne votre politique
africaine réussie aux Aï mais échoué au
Tchad et au centraafrique pourquoi et à
cause de quoi et vous monsieur êtes-vous
sûr qu'on puisse aussi en Afrique
autrement qu'avec des hommes dont
certains effectivement sont des
dictateurs à nos yeux qui répond en
premier vous
voulez monsieur vant vous êtes un tout
petit peu en retard vous avez un peu de
retardz l'affaire du zaï vous voulez
dire
colvis l'intervention militaire en
d'intervention de sauvetage à l'égard
des des Français qui se trouvaient à
col ce que je pense c'est que la façon
dont le gouvernement français s'est
comporté l'égard du président Mobutu
responsable de ce pays qui se trouvait
affronté à une grave crise de caractère
séparatiste il faut le dire avec une
large
provinceon de conditions ethniques bien
connues des spécialistes le Shabat que
le comportement du gouvernement français
a indiscutablement provoqué très graves
difficultés avec la population
intéressée de Shabat qui a considéré que
la France se comportait en adversaire et
à partir de là cette colère s'est
retourné dans une large part contre nos
compatriotes et le gouvernement a bien
fait à partir de là d'aller d'aller les
sauver seulement ça faisait déjà très
longtemps que l'on était informé des
menaces qui pouvaient peser sur cette
population bref on aurait pu rapatrier
plutôt si on y avait
pensé je parlerai du Centre-Afrique tout
à l'heure si vous voulez pour ce qui
concerne le
Centre-Afrique je pense que je suis
interven simplement de vous demander de
presser un tout petit peu car n nous
approchons de la limite 50 à laquelle
nous devons interrompre pour que vous
puissiez conclure je suis intervenu en
1972 à l'Assemblée nationale pour
interpeller comme on dit le gouvernement
de l'époque le ministre le ministre des
Affaires étrangè était monsieur Maurice
Schumann pour faire état de terribles
choses qui se passaient dans ce pays
sous
l'autorité de celui qui était à l'époque
le président
bookasa euh des crimes de toutes sortte
14 parlementaires français de droite de
gauche après moi au cours de ces
dernières années sont intervenus de la
même façon c'està dire ont alerté les
responsables des pouvoirs publics et
c'est ce que je reproche essentiellement
au président de la République et au
gouvernement c'est de ne pas avoir tenu
compte de ces avertissements et d'avoir
continué de
considérer ce régime comme supportable
disons au-delà de ce que l'on peut
admettre dans les relations d'état à
état même avec des dictatures je
reconnais que c'est un problème moral
difficile mais il y a un point limite
qui indiscutablement mes yeux a été
dépassé l'Afrique ce n'est pas l'Europe
ce n'est pas la France c'est un
continent très important pour nous c'est
un continent qui a des problèmes
politiques et sociaux qui sont
différents des nôtres et donc il ne faut
pas juger collectivement les situations
dans les différents états africains
comme vous le faisiez on peut dire dans
toute dis distingué dans toute l'Afrique
de l'Ouest la situation a évolué de
façon positive et même nous avons pu
Renou des relations avec des états avec
lesquels nous les avions interrompus je
pense par exemple à la Guinée je pense à
l'heure actuelle au Bénin donc il y a eu
incontestablement un développement de
relations et une consolidation des liens
politiques avec toute cette partie de
l'Afrique au Zaïr qui n'est pas une
ancienne possession française nous nous
sommes trouvés face à une situation qui
était d'extrême urgence on pouvait
imaginer qu'il se produirait tel ou tel
mouvement au Aïr mais enfin les
autorités elles-mêmes ne le savaient pas
puisqu'elles ne l'avaient pas prévu les
autorités locales qui n'étaient pas
français les entreprises qui sont là
vous le savez sont les entreprises
minières Bell je ne l'avais pas prévu
non plus les événements ont commencé un
dimanche et les massacres ont commencé
le jeudi et la question qui s'est posé à
moi est de savoir si je devais prendre
les dispositions nécessaires et prendre
la décision de faire interrompre ce
massacre j'ai donc pris avec le ministre
de la Défense chef d'état-major des
armées la décision de faire partir un
régime entier de parachutiste et de le
faire sauter à une distance éloigné de
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres de la
France sur un terrain que nous ne
connaissions pas et nous n'avions aucun
moyen de les récupérer si les choses
tournaient de façon difficile alors
maintenant en effet tout le monde dit il
était bien de le faire personne ne m'a
soutenu j'ai relu encore les
déclarations qui ont été faites dans la
journée du vendredi où j'étais à
l'Élysée 1 minute 30 monsieur jiscbtin 1
minute 30 il vous reste une minute 20
encore un autre sujet et oui justement
alors vous avez votre conclusion alors
le centreafrique et quant à la
centra-afrique effectivement le régime
centrafricain donnait prise à beaucoup
de critiqu les événements dont vous
parliez en 1972 je je n'était pas
président de la République la question
qui s'est posée était de savoir si nous
pouvions intervenir plus directement
dans les affaires de la Centrafrique qui
était voisine du Tchad Tchad qui
lui-même était en état de grande crise
politique et militaire comme vous le
savez et qui nous amenait une attitude
en effet dont on peut juger que elle
aurait pu être différente à condition de
prendre le risque d'abandonner la
Centrafrique finalement ce que nous
avons pu perire c'est obtenir le départ
du chef d'État par les Centrafricains
eux-mêmes et l'instauration d'un régime
qui vient de tenir des élections et qui
commence à conduire une vie démocratique
dans ce pays merci une question monsieur
miteron concernant les problèmes
militaires sur le même sujet je voudrais
quand même faire observer qu'avec
l'affaire du Centre-Afrique l'affaire du
Tchad l'histoire de nos relations avec
la Libye songeer que pendant que l'on
soutenait le gouvernement 1 une fraction
du Tchad que certains de nos soldats
exposés dans leur vie pendant ce temps
on continuit d'armer la Libye il y a eu
un double jeu là qui é qui je crois nous
a fait perdre beaucoup d'autorité dans
l'ensemble des pays d'Afrique
aujourd'hui après l'affaire du
Centre-Afrique et l'affaire de la Libye
plus l'affaire du chchad le poids moral
et politique de la France a diminué je
le regrette al sur ce point vous vous
trompez tout à fait le poids politique
et moral de la France est au contraire
très élevé en Afrique j'en ai reçu les
témoignages de la quasi totalité des
chefs d'État africains récemment
simplement je n'ai pas voulu en faire
état dans cette campagne s été déplacé
et en ce qui concerne la Libye vous
savez fort bien que nos livraisons
d'armes été interrompu dès le début des
événements d'intervention militaire
libyen a ch question vous n'avez pas une
question vous n'avez pas vendu on n'a
pas vendu par vous naturellement on n
pas vendu des tonnes d'Ang Matra des
fusées en décembre à la Libye à ma
connaissance non nous avons très bien à
ma connaissance et et un mot monsieur
mérant sur les problèmes militaires si
vous deviez être en charge de la
responsabilité de président de la
République seriez-vous favorable ou non
à la construction d'une bombe à neutron
c'est-à-dire cet armement nucléaire de
moyenne portée qui agit sur des troupes
ennemis sans détruire les territoires
dans lesquels allait utilisé réponse en
une minute c'est une bombe d'une portée
assez réduite qui s'inscrit dans une
autre stratégie que la stratégie de
dissuasion nucléaire c'est ce qu'on
appelle la bataille de l'avant elle
implique que des discussions est eu lieu
entre les Alliés et de ce point de vue
je pense que la France sous l'autorité
de Monsieur jcardestin n'était pas prête
à cela il y a donc un problème qui se
pose et je ne suis pas favorable à la
construction de la bombe à neutro c'est
votre avis aussi monsieur non mon avis
est tout à fait différent la France doit
pouvoir disposer de tous les moyens
d'armement modernes pour faire face à
tous les types de situations possibles
et en particulier elle ne doit pas
prendre de retard nous n'avons pas
décidé la fabrication mais nous avons
pris les dispositions nécessaires pour
que nous puissions être capable de la
fabriquer si nous le décidions ainsi
alors nous nous rejoignons alors merci
vous êtes tous les deux presque égalité
à 10 secondes d'écart et au terme de
Monsieur miteron il vous reste une
minute si vous le voulez par rapport à
Monsieur giscardestin si vous souhaitez
sur ce point précis pour ne pas relancer
le débat et ne pas imposer à Monsieur
giscardestin de vous écouter sans
pouvoir vous répondre dire un mot vous
pouvez le faire nous vous demandons
simplement de le faire de tel sorte que
Monsieur jardin ne soit pas contraint de
vous répondre car lui il ne lui reste
qu'une seule seconde mais je suis tout
prêt à passer une partie de mon modeste
temps à Monsieur jardestin pour qu'il me
réponde à la question que je lui pose à
propos d'Israël pourquoi le gouvernement
de français a-t-il été à ce point
hostile aux accords de Camp David alors
que c'était une marche vers la paix et
d'autre part pourquoi est-il allé en
Jordanie pour observer ce qui était d'un
symbole fâcheux le territoire israélien
d'un fortin de Jordanie et maintenant je
lui donne le reste de mon temps s'il le
souhaite pour pouvoir le répondre je
sais pas pr la commiss cont si les deux
intéressés sont d'accord il vous reste
donc monsieur
guscardestin quelques 40 secondes pour
non peut pas répondre à une telle
question en 40 secondes ou bien vous
donner du temps une minute ou deux je
réponds pas nous on vous donnerit
volontié tout le temps vous voulez
maisan a je pense que la Commission de
contrôle acceptera le consentement
mutuel des candidats
al sur la question d'Israël monsieur
vous prononcé une phrase que je n'ai
jamais prononcé j'en ai le texte sous
les yeux c'est l'expression État
palestinien je connais le sens et la
portée des mots dans cette affaire du
Proche Orient je n'ai jamais prononcé le
mot d'État palestin j'ai parlé
d'autodétermination du peuple
palestinien avec ensuite des
développements politiques jamais d'état
vous avez parlé des rapports entre les
deux état État palestinien et État
d'Israël j'ai ici votre déclaration
écrite deuxièmement la photo qui a été
présenter me représentant regardant
Israël avec des jumelles vous savez où
elle a été
prise m'en suis pas intéressé et bien
c'est intéressant à l'hippodrome de
Longchamp où j'étais au Prix de l'Arc de
Triomphe mais est-ce que vous étiez là
la photo qui a été montrée photo ou vous
je suis allé en Jordanie tout le monde
le sait je ne suis allé aucunement et
j'ai au contraire demandé à ce qu'il n
être aucune présence journalistique car
j'allais visiter les installations
agricoles du fleuve du Jourdain à
l'invitation du gouvernement jordanien
et quand j'ai vu qu'il était question
d'installation militaire j'ai dit je
refuse de visiter des installations
militaires la photo qui a été montrée il
faut le savoir est une photo prise à
l'hippodrome de Longchamp je dis pour
les français pour qu'il soit éclairé sur
un certain nombre de procédés
quant à la question de quand David j'ai
reçu récemment le président Sadat
président Sadat m'a dit et m'a écrit à
son départ je reconnais que c'est vous
qui aviez raison vous avez raison sur le
point suivant c'est que ce qui est
important pour le proche orient c'est
d'arriver à une paix globale il n'y aura
de sécurité pour Israël et bien entendu
nous ne ferons jamais rien qui mette en
danger la sécurité d'Israël il n'y aura
de sécurité que s'il y a une paix
globale or dans le dispositif de cand
David il y avait des dispositions
intéressantes vous vous en souvenez
l'autonomie de la sjordanie dont j'ai
dit qu' que vous n'aboutiriez jamais à
les mettre au coin c'est tout ce que
j'ai dit or il y a un an que ces
dispositions aurent dû être adopté elles
ne le sont pas encore à l'heure actuelle
s'il y a un progrès d'ici la fin de
l'année pour aboutir à la conclusion de
ce processus j'ai indiqué récemment à
mes visiteurs israéliens que nous
accueillerions positivement la
conclusion de telle disposition bien
messieur le temps de débat est donc
terminé il vous reste un temps de
conclusion qui est pour l'un et pour
l'autre de 5 minutes euh nous aurions
aimé je vous le dis parce que cela ne
mort pas sur votre temps vous posez une
question de caractère général mais
peut-être s'inscrira-t-elle dans votre
propre conclusion c'est pourquoi je
l'exprime nous nous étions demandés à
l'AVEC de cette échéance fondamentale
dans la vie politique française
qu'est-ce qu'au fond chacun d'entre vous
proposiez au français entre les grands
projets que l'on peut imaginer et nous
en
avions isolé TR s'agit-il pour la France
aujourd'hui de la mobiliser pour faire
face à des temps
difficiles s'agit-il de lui promettre le
bonheur et le niveau de vie en
progression rapide pour tout le monde ou
s'agit-il de lui demander de faire un
effort dans la grandeur qui peut
comporter des
sacrifices vous pouvez ou pas répondre à
ces questions vous avez maintenant le
temps de parole libre chacun 5 minutes
en commençant par Monsieur Valéri
gesserdestin puisque le en a ainsi
décidé c'est une conclusion dont je
m'adresse plus à François mitteran il le
comprendra je m'adresse aux
téléspectateurs je souhaitais que ce
débat soit utile et je l'ai conduis
d'ailleurs mon interlocuteur également
de telle façon qu'il soit utile
c'est-à-dire que vous connaissiez mieux
la position de l'un et de l'autre au
terme de ce débat vous avez vu d'abord
qu'il y avait le choix entre deux
majorités de type tout à fait différent
une majorité à partir de la majorité
actuelle sans dissolution au cas où je
suis élu président de la République une
dissolution conduisante à une majorité
alternative c'est-à-dire composé
principalement de socialistes et de
communistes dans le cas où Monsieur
miteran
serait-il le deuxième point qui était
important éit de savoir dans quelle
direction nous engagions l'économie et
la société française je crois que les
Français aspirent à davantage de liberté
et de responsabilité je crois que c'est
leur aspiration profonde elle s'est
d'ailleurs exprimé largement au cours de
cette campagne ce qui veut dire moins de
tutelle moins de bureaucratie moins
d'intervention mon interlocuteur disait
tout à l'heure la bureaucratie c'est
vous mais il propose de recruter 160000
fonctionnaires supplémentaires alors que
dans mon programme il n'y a vous le
savez aucune création d'emploi de plus
dans la fonction publique et d'autre
part il propose l'extension massive du
secteur nationalisé c'est-à-dire la
perte de la vitalité et de la
responsabilité d'une partie importante
de l'industrie française ce sont donc
deux directions complètement différentes
concernant les mesures économiques et
sociales je crois que nous sommes
engagés dans une direction où nous
devons continuer d'avancer c'est
pourquoi j'ai proposé des mesures
précises concernant l'emploi des jeunes
et je souhaite que l'assemblée d sa
réunion c'est-à-dire à la moitié du mois
de mai si je suis élu puisse adopter des
mesures favorables précisément à
l'amélioration de l'emploi des jeunes en
ce qui concerne l'économie je vous dis
que l'économie française ne résistera
pas à une injection de dépenses hostile
aux accords de Camp David alors que
c'était une marche vers la paix et
d'autre part pourquoi est-il allé en
Jordanie pour observer ce qui était une
d'un symbole fâcheux le territoire
israélien d'un fortin de Jordanie et
maintenant je lui donne le reste de mon
temps s'il le souhaite pour pouvoir n
répondre je sais pas si c'est pr par la
commission deôle si les deux intéressés
sont d'accord il vous reste donc
monsieur juscard desestin quelques 40
secondes pour non on peut pas répondre à
une telle question en 40 secondes ou
bien vous me donnez du temps une minute
de je réponds pas nous on vous donz
volontier tout le temps vous voulez
maisement de contrôle acceptera le
consentement mutuel des candidats
alors sur la question d'Israël monsieur
mitérant vous avez prononcé une phrase
que je n'ai jamais prononcé j'en ai le
texte sous les yeux c'est l'expression
État palestinien je connais le sens et
la portée des mots dans cette affaire du
Proche Orient je n'ai jamais prononcé le
mot d'État palestinien j'ai parlé
d'autodétermination du peuple
palestinien avec ensuite des
développements politiques jamais d'état
vous avez parlé des rapports entre les
deux états État palestinien et État
d'Israël j'ai ici votre déclaration
écrite deuxièmement la photo qui a été
présentée me représentant regardant
Israël avec des jumelles vous savez où
elle a été prise vous sa pas m'en suis
pas intéressé et bien c'est intéressant
à l'hippodrome de Longchamp où j'étais
au Prix de l'Arc de triomp ou mais
est-ce que vous étiez là la photo qui a
été montrée la photo oui mais vous je
suis allé en Jordanie tout le monde le
sait je ne suis allé aucunement et j'ai
au contraire demandé à ce qu'il n ait
aucune présence journalistique car
j'allais visiter les installations
agricoles du fleuve du Jourdain à
l'invitation du gouvernement jordanien
et quand j'ai vu qu'il était question
d'installation militaire j'ai dit je
refuse de visiter des installations
militaires la photo qui a été montrée il
faut le savoir est une photo prise à
l'hippodrome de Longchamp je dis pour
les français pour qu'il soit éclairé sur
un certain nombre de procédés quant à la
question de cand David j'ai reçu
récemment le président Sadat président
Sadat m'a dit et m'a écrit à son départ
je reconnais que vous qui aviez raison
vous avez raison sur le point suivant
c'est que ce qui est important pour le
proche orient c'est d'arriver à une paix
globale il n'y aura de sécurité pour
Israël et bien entendu nous ne ferons
jamais rien qui met en danger la
sécurité d'Israël il n'y aura de
sécurité que s'il y a une paix globale
or dans le dispositif de cand David il y
avait des dispositions intéressant vous
vous en souvenez l'autonomie de laassise
Jordanie dont j'ai dit qu' que vous
n'aboutiriez jamais à les mettre au
point c'est tout ce que j'ai dit or il y
a un an que ces dispositions ait dû être
AD elles ne le sont pas encore à l'heure
actuelle s'il y a un progrès d'ici la
fin de l'année pour aboutir à la
conclusion de ce processus j'ai indiqué
récemment à mes visiteurs israéliens que
nous accueillerions positivement la
conclusion de telle disposition bien
messieur le temps de débat est donc
terminé il vous reste un temps de
conclusion qui est pour l'un et pour
l'autre de 5
minutes nous aurions aimé je vous le dis
parce que cela ne mort pas sur votre
temps vous posez une question de
caractère général mais peut-être
s'inscrira-t-elle dans votre propre
conclusion c'est pourquoi je l'exprime
nous nous étions demandés à l'aveille de
cette échéance fondamental dans la vie
politique française qu'est-ce qu'au fond
chacun d'entre vous proposiez aux
Français entre les grands projets que
l'on peut imaginer et nous en
avions isolé trois s'agit-il pour la
France aujourd'hui de la mobiliser pour
faire face à des temps
difficiles sagit-il de lui promettre le
bonheur et le niveau de vie en
progression rapide pour tout le monde ou
s'agit-il de lui demander de faire un
effort dans la grandeur qui peut
comporter des
sacrifices vous pouvez ou pas répondre à
ces questions vous avez maintenant le
temps de parole libre chacun 5 minutes
en commençant par Monsieur Valéri
gdestin puisque le sort en a ainsi
décidé c'est une conclusion dont je
m'adresse plus à François mitan il le
comprendra je m'adresse au
téléspectateurs je souhaitait que ce
débat soit utile et je l'ai conduis
d'ailleurs mon interlocuteur également
de telle façon qu'il soit utile
c'est-à-dire que vous connaissiez mieux
la position de l'une et de l'autre au
terme de ce débat vous avez vu d'abord
qu'il y avait le choix entre deux
majorités de type tout à fait différent
une majorité à partir de la majorité
actuelle sans dissolution au cas où je
suis élu président de la République une
dissolution conduisante à une majorité
alternative c'est-à-dire composé
principalement de socialistes et de
communistes dans le cas monsieur
mitteran serait élu le deuxième point
qui était important était de savoir dans
quelle direction nous engagions
l'économie et la société française je
crois que les Français aspirent à
davantage de liberté et de
responsabilité je crois que c'est leur
aspiration profonde elle s'est
d'ailleurs exprimé largement au cours de
cette campagne ce qui veut dire moins de
tutelle moins de bureaucratie moins
d'intervention mon interlocuteur me
disait tout à l'heure la bureaucratie
c'est vous mais il propose de recruter
160000 fonctionnaires supplémentaires
alors que dans mon programme il n'y a
vous le savez aucune création d' fois de
plus dans la fonction publique et
d'autre part il propose l'extension
massive du secteur nationalisé
c'est-à-dire la perte de la vitalité et
de la responsabilité d'une partie
importante de l'industrie française ce
sont donc deux directions complètement
différentes concernant les mesures
économiques et sociales je crois que
nous sommes engagés dans une direction
où nous devons continuer d'avancer c'est
pourquoi j'ai proposé des mesures
précise concernant l'emploi des jeunes
et je souhaite que l'assemblée des sa
réunion c'est-à-dire à la moitié du mois
de mai si je suis élu puisse adopter des
mesures favorables précisément à
l'amélioration de l'emploi des jeunes en
ce qui concerne l'économie je vous dis
que l'économie française ne résistera
pas à une injection de dépenses et de
charges nouvelles naturellement c'est
enant dans une première phase mais il
faut voir que très vite ces charges il
faudra les payer soit vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur parce que nous aurons des
importations massives attiré par notre
supplément de demande intérieure et
notre déf se creusera soit sur le plan
de nos finances publiques et de nos
impôts parce que notre déficit
budgétaire augmentera mon interlocuteur
le reconnaissait tout à l'heure et que
tôt ou tard il faudra créer des
ressources pour y faire face et je vous
dis qu'à l'heure actuelle dans le monde
tel qu'il est avec les difficultés
économique que nous avons l'économie
française n'est pas en état de faire
face à de telles surcharges et chacun de
vous qui croira pouvoir vivre mieux
vivra en réalité plus mal j'ai le devoir
de le lui dire en ce qui concerne la
politique extérieure je tiendrait bien
entendu les grands principes de la
politique que vous avez vu se dérouler
pendant 7 ans c'est-à-dire la sécurité
de la France appuyé sur son important
dispositif de sécurité et en même temps
la participation à la vie internationale
pour combattre comme je l'ai fait et
malgré les critique pour la cause de la
paix je vrais vous dire en conclusion et
je ne polémiquerai pas avec mon
interlocuteur je le souhaite pas il y a
quelque chose qui joue pour lui c'est le
goût du changement des Français et ce
goût existe et dans le passé d'ailleurs
il nous a joué beaucoup de mauvais tours
parce que on croit toujours que ce qui
sera nouveau sera meilleur il arrive
souvent malheureusement dans les temps
difficiles que ce qui est nouveau soit
au contraire pire et plus difficile or
nous avons tenu un débat ensemble en
1974 peut-être même d'ailleurs dans
cette pièce j'observe en l'écoutant que
ce qu'il dit n'est pas changer
naturellement ce n'est plus le programme
commun mais c'est dans la ligne du
programme commun ce sont les mêmes
alliances politique alliance politique
avec le Parti communiste et donc
finalement ce sont les mêmes
propositions remises naturellement au
goût de l'événement et de l'actualité et
au contraire moi j'ai
changé parce que j'ai eu à supporter le
poids de la conduite des affaires de la
France pendant 7 ans et ceci m'a changé
c'était des temps qui étaient dur et
difficile il vous reste moins d'une
minute non il me reste oui moins d'une
minute j'ai appris par ce que
j'appellerai la voix dure et en même
temps il m'est arrivé je le sais d'avoir
tort et je ne crois pas m'abaisser en le
10 ans mais je me suis battu pour la
France et pour les Français et je crois
que cette action au lieu de m'éloigner
d'eux en réalité m'a rapprocher deux si
bien que l'expérience que j'ai acquise
me permettra mieux qu'auparavant
d'exercer les fonctions de président de
la République au travers de tout ce que
j'ai vu entendu et fait dont je prends
la responsabilité pendant ces 7 ans j'ai
me suis transformé et préparé à exercer
je le crois une présidence qui sera une
présidence de progrès pour la France et
j'indique que ce que je souhaite c'est
mobiliser ces forces en effet pour le
progrès de l'avenir de la France que je
souhaite avec vous porter très loin
merci Monsieur François
mit j'évoquerai d'abord les questions
que j'aurais aimé traiter ce soir mais
voilà les conditions d'un débat sont
toujours incertaines
j'aurais aimé parler davantage du Tiers
Monde j'aurais aimé parler de l'Amérique
central des drames qui se déroulent
actuellement au Nicaragua au Salvador du
rôle de la France force morale pays
d'incitation pour comprendre que
désormais il n'y a plus que des
politiques planétaires dans l'intérêt
même de nos
peuples j'aurais aimé parler de problème
touchant à la vie nationale en
profondeur parler des mutations
technologiques au fond si nous n'avons
pas été en mesure de traiter le chômage
comme il convenait c'est parce que nous
n'avons pas assez prévu les responsables
de la France le phénomène extraordinaire
de la mutation technologique de
l'arrivée comme cela sur le marché du
travail de machines sophistiquées
extraordinaires qui peuvent à tout
moment remplacer la force de l'homme et
remplacer son intelligence et remplacer
sa mémoire et pourtant il faut bien que
les hommes que les femmes trouvent du
travail agissent et c'est un type de
civilisation type de civilisation de
liberté qui n'a pas été entrepris comme
il convenait par le septena par son
président entre 1974 et
1981 j'entends bien naturellement
lorsque je parle du chômage de de la
nécessité de lutter pour l'emploi un
certain nombre d'observations un peu
rondeuses et mécontente et quelquefois
se voulant professoral et je m'en amuse
parfois un peu qu'on me pardonne cette
expression en pensant que la situation
de Monsieur J gardestin c'est un peu il
me permettra de le dire celle d'un
conducteur qui vient de verser sa
voiture dans le fussé et qui viendrait
me demander pour me surveiller de
repasser mon permis de conduire en
vérité il y a une politique du passé
c'est celle qui s'achève maintenant en
1981 il y a une autre politique possible
c'est celle que je développe déjà depuis
plusieurs années et notamment au cours
de ces deux derniers mois pendant
lesquels j'ai dit partout comme je le
pouvais ce que j'entendais faire si
j'étais élu président de la République
et ce que j'entends faire surtout c'est
la défense de la liberté je sais bien
qu'on peut débattre après tout il faut
pas toujours accuser les autres de
vouloir attenter à NS liberté mais la
liberté c'est un mot bien abstrait il
faut le traiter dans sa réalité
quotidienne quelle est la liberté d'un
chômeur quelle est la liberté de
quelqu'un qui sans être chômeur
travaille à des cadences
infernales la liberté sera sauve garder
si nous préservons l'équilibre des
pouvoirs et le président de la
République sous le subténat de Monsieur
J cardestin a abusé s emparé du
gouvernement de la République il s'est
emparé de en réalité de la vie
parlementaire il agit sur la justice il
agit sur l'information par les moyens de
duisuel la liberté elle tient à la
décentralisation des pouvoirs au fait
que l'État cède une large part de son
pouvoir aux régions au département au
communes aux associations c'est ça qui
nous permettra de lutter utilement
contre la bureaucratie r la liberté
c'est la diffusion du savoir c'estd le
développement de l'école la possibilité
pour les les enfants d'acquérir les
chances l'égalité des chances dans la
vie leur intelligence leur caractère de
ne pas être rejetés parce qu'ils ont des
enfants pauvres de famille pauvres ils
doivent avoir autant de chance que les
autres la liberté c'est aussi la
conquête des droits sociaux des droits
des droits collectifs des responsabilité
moi je pense à une société dans laquelle
le socialisme permettra le développement
de la responsabilité de chaque individu
à l'intérieur de l'entreprise dans la
cité de façon à ce que la liberté
supérieure ça s'appelle la
responsabilité c'est comme cela qu'on
aura une société plus harmonieuse où
chacun sera plus libre la liberté c'est
encore la défense contre la certains
effets de la science et de la technique
on a parlé du nucléaire on aurait pu
parler de la biologie faut-il parler de
l'informatique et de la menace qu'elle
fait peser par exemple sur de nombreuses
entreprise de presse de la de la presse
écrite dans la mesure où un pouvoir
central un gouvernement pourrait se
substituer aux informations de la presse
la liberté c'est aussi la conquête du
temps de vivre il faut bien vivre la vie
c'est pas simplement une annexe du
travail il faut organiser le temps de
travail nécessaire c'est pourquoi l'axe
principal de bon action c'est la lutte
contre le chômage mais aussi le temps de
vivre faire que qu'une femme on pas
parler des droits de la femme qu'un
enfant qu'un homme enfin que tous ceux
qui participent à la vie de notre cité
puissent apprendre à mieux vivre et à
vivre autrement enfin il y a un problème
de liberté qui se pose sur le plan
international on en a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est le droit des peuples à
disposer de même pour cela il nous faut
un instrument cet instrument c'est ça
commence par la présidence de la
République c'est-à-dire par le
changement le changement de président
qui entraînera un changement de
politique avec un changement de majorité
le changement pourquoi faire pour
essayer de rassembler j'ai eu avec moi
d'abord les socialistes je vois la la
gauche se rassembler aujourd'hui dans un
puissant mouvement populaire je voudrais
que cela aille plus loin et que la
France se sente à l'aise avec elle-même
la grandeur de la France croire en elle
la France est quelque chose de fort qui
doit être respecté je ne condamne pas
tout ce qui a été fait c'est l'histoire
de la France et j'en hériterai mais je
voudrais pousser plus loin peut-être
réformer ou corriger et ce qui me
permettra de réformer et de corriger
c'est de parvenir à établir dans un pays
comme la France un peu plus d'égalité
qu'on apprenne à vivre ensemble dans une
société développée et harmonieuse c'est
tout ce que je veux faire merci Monsieur
pour pour ce débat nous aussi nous
aurions eu bien d'autres questions à
vous poser nous espérons néanmoins que
ce débat aura éclairé les Français sur
vos choix et votre politique mais
désormais les Français sont les seuls à
répondre par leur vote au nom de Jean
boissen au revoir et
merci
21 minutes 10
secondes